Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Forschergeist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die deutsche Wissenschaft.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zu Nummer 59 unserer Gesprächsserie,
wo wir uns um Wissenschaft und auch viel schon über Bildung unterhalten haben und das ist auch ein Fokus heute.
Und das hat mich dieses Mal in die Schweiz geführt, genauer nach Zürich und ich sitze jetzt hier an der Universität Zürich,
im Institut für Erziehungswissenschaften und begrüße meinen Gesprächspartner für heute,
nämlich Philippe Wampfler, schönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Philip du bist Lehrer, kann man mal ganz zurückhaltend sagen, aber jemand,
der sich mehr als der Durchschnitt mit digitalen Fragen auseinandergesetzt hat.
Wie digital bist du denn aufgewachsen?
Ja ich bin so mitteldigital aufgewachsen, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe mehr so aus einer Anwärterperspektive habe ich schon als Kind eigentlich Computerspiele gespielt,
so Adventures und als ich dann begonnen habe, wirklich als Lehrer zu arbeiten,
da habe ich das erste Mal wirklich ins Netz geschrieben.
Ich glaube so meine erste Aktivität, ich habe so Amazon-Rezensionen geschrieben,
das war dann so schon fast blogartig, also so im Sinne von, schnell waren das mal 1-2 Rezensionen pro Tag, die ich geschrieben habe.
Und daraus hat sich dann so die Blogs entwickelt, dann besonders auch Twitter,
das ist sicher so ein Meilenstein gewesen, dass ich dort so gemerkt habe, dass ist jetzt eigentlich so mein Medium
oder dort finde ich auch Leute, die ich dann so kennenlerne und die ich dann später wieder an Anlässen treffe
und so ergibt sich dann so ein Netzwerk, das war sicher eine prägende Erfahrung.
Warum hast du denn mit Rezensionen angefangen?
Ja ich habe auch viel gelesen so als Deutschlehrer und Germanist und dann fand ich einfach interessant,
so kurze Meinungen zu schreiben und gewissen Perspektiven zu verdeutlichen.
Das war so etwas, was ich zum ersten Mal dort so gesehen habe, dass es möglich war.
Ach nee, so Hattrick das habe ich auch noch gespielt, das war so ein Fußballmanager
und dort gab es auch ein Forum und dort habe ich ganz viele Themen diskutiert.
Also da gab es natürlich dann so die ganze Palette von Themen und das war auch so eine Aktivität, was ich interessant fand.
Also alles aus diesem Antrieb heraus, seine eigene Meinung zu teilen, kann man das sagen?
Ja, ich habe es sehr gemocht so in diesen WG-Zeiten so Diskussionen zu führen und bis in die Nacht hinein so gewisse Standpunkte auszutauschen.
Und davon bin ich schon ein bisschen getrieben, auch im Netz halt wirklich zu sehen,
ja wo komme ich mit meiner Meinung hin oder wer widerspricht da und was passiert dann,
wenn wir uns argumentativ austauschen, ich denke, das ist einfach Teil meiner Persönlichkeit, dass ich das sehr gern mache.
Mhm. Und dann ging es relativ früh dann mit den Blogs los?
Ja.
2006 war ja die ganze Blogosphäre, da gab es glaube ich diesen Begriff schon,
aber es war ja noch sehr überschaubar mit ganz anderen Berühmtheiten im Netz, als man das jetzt vielleicht heute wahrnehmen würde.
Wie hast du das wahrgenommen, diese Welt, die sich da aufgetan hat?
Ja, ich habe begonnen vielleicht so ein bisschen mit Medienkritik hauptsächlich.
Also ich habe sehr viele Zeitungen gelesen und da war so in der Schweiz gerade so die Welle,
wo auch Gratiszeitungen hochgekommen sind.
In Deutschland haben die sich ja nie durchgesetzt, weil die Verleger sich da wirklich dagegen positioniert haben.
In der Schweiz war das etwas anders.
Da gab es so eine Zeit lang 3-4 Gratistitel, die ganz viele Dinge abgedruckt haben und auch fragwürdige,
so wie Grenzen überschritten haben und das habe ich dann so im Netz als erstes so ausgedrückt
und da natürlich gemerkt, da gibt es ganz viele andere Leute, die auch schon unterwegs waren.
Ich war sicher nicht einer der ersten in der Schweiz, der so in dieser Blogosphäre war,
da gab es viele andere, die bestimmte Themen abgedeckt haben, auch viel mehr Pioniercharakter hatten als ich.
Und dann hat es sich ein bisschen gewandelt, als ich mich wirklich auch mit Schulthemen auseinandergesetzt habe.
Also ich hatte die Möglichkeit, eine Weiterbildung durchzuführen, und die wollte ich halt auf einem Blog auch vorbereiten
und das hat dann so dazu geführt, dass ich das mehr auch professionell gemacht habe.
Und das war auch so die Zeit, in der die großen Debatten so in der Piratenpartei liefen
und dann habe ich so auch versucht, mich da so ein bisschen einzuklinken, auch viel mitgelesen und gesehen,
wie schnell diese Dynamiken sind, auch wie politisch bestimmte Fragen dann plötzlich werden.
Also so die ganzen Datenschutzfragen oder auch die Fragen der Bildung, wie in sagen wir schulfernen Institutionen,
dass da auch Bildungsprozesse ablaufen, Lernprozesse ablaufen, das hat mir schon vieles geöffnet.
Und dann natürlich war das auch ein Tor, um die Diskussion besonders auch in den USA, in England auch mitzubekommen,
wo diese Edu-Blogs eine viel längere Tradition haben als in Deutschland, würde ich sagen.
War das nicht sogar so, dass einige dieser Blogeinträge zu dieser Medienkritik auch über die Blogosphäre hinaus Aufmerksamkeit erlangt haben?
Oder zumindest in der Blogosphäre stärkere Aufmerksamkeit?
Ja das gab es schon.
Also eine Geschichte, die besonders viele Wellen geworfen hat, das war so eine Hooligan-Geschichte,
und zwar habe ich mit den Schülerinnen und Schülern über den Presserat gesprochen,
das ist so diese Institution, bei der man fragwürdige Begebenheiten in den Medien melden kann
und die nehmen dann Stellung dazu, also da kann eigentlich jede Person eine Beschwerde einreichen.
Und das habe ich dann auch ein bisschen durchgespielt, weil ich das mit der Klasse besprochen habe
und irgendwie zeigen wollte, das ist tatsächlich möglich, da was zu tun.
Und es ging um einen Fan des FCZ, des Fußballclubs hier in Zürich und der wurde bei einem Auswärtsspiel in Rom wurde der verletzt von der Petarde, die explodiert ist
und dann gab es eine Medienkampagne im Boulevard dagegen, die so gesagt hat, das ist der Petarden-Trottel von Rom.
Dass er eigentlich selbst schuld daran war an dieser Verletzung und das fand ich sehr entwürdigend,
wie diese Kampagne verlaufen ist und dagegen habe ich dann Beschwerde eingereicht
und das wurde dann schon in den Medien aufgegriffen.
Das war also das erste Mal, dass ich gemerkt habe, da schwappt was über, was jetzt so sich anfüllt, als wäre es nur im Netz,
und dann plötzlich hat das auch Berichte in so Tageszeitungen nach sich gezogen und Leute haben sehr stark darauf reagiert,
besonders diese Fans haben natürlich sofort sich organisiert.
Und dann habe ich so echte Reaktionen auch von den Eltern von diesem Betroffenen,
die haben mir gedankt, dass ich versuche habe, das Bild zu korrigieren.
Dann habe ich gemerkt, das betrifft auch … das ist mehr als nur so eine Fingerübung für mich,
sondern da ist auch eine Form von Aktivismus vielleicht möglich.
Wann war das genau?
Das müsste ich jetzt nachsehen, wann das genau war.
Ungefähr?
Ich würde sagen, so ungefähr vor 10 Jahren.
Aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch so eine der wenigen Meldungen, die damals quasi in die breite Öffentlichkeit aus Blogs heraus reingeschwappt sind oder?
Ja, das war schon eine der wenigen, wobei dann ziemlich bald hat das auch angefangen,
dass die Zeitungen begonnen haben, Tweets abzudrucken, und sich so ein bisschen die Debatten im Netz angeschaut haben und darauf reagiert haben,
aber ja das war schon eine Ausnahme, also das ist nicht sehr oft passiert.
Aber mittlerweile ist das schon etwas, wo ich so dran denke, dass ich weiß, wenn ich jetzt einem Missstand begegne
oder wenn ich auf etwas reagieren will, dann kann ich das schon im Netz auch lostreten oder eine bestimmte Aufmerksamkeit da auch generieren.
Das ist jetzt heute wie selbstverständlich geworden.
Also du hast auf jeden Fall so eine – ich interpretiere das jetzt mal als eine – relativ natürliche Herangehensweise an die digitalen Medien.
Es war irgendwie immer da, du hast irgendwie die Klaviatur einfach mal selber benutzt, um zu gucken, was da für Töne bei rauskommen
und darüber quasi erste Erfahrungen gesammelt, außerhalb eines Schulbetriebs.
mhm (bejahend)
Weil eigentlich bist du ja Lehrer.
Wenn ich es richtig sehe, Germanistik, Mathe und auch Philosophie war glaube ich im Studium dabei.
Genau ja.
Mit irgendeinem Schwerpunkt oder wirklich so alles gleichzeitig?
Ja, mein Schwerpunkt war dann schon neue Literatur eigentlich und da habe ich auch mal so ein Dissertationsprojekt gehabt,
das habe ich dann im Zuge dieser Publikationen im Netz habe ich das dann auch aufgegeben
und es ist immer noch so etwas, was noch so ein bisschen als Frage im Raum steht, müsste man so, wenn ich so die Dinge, die ich mache,
müsste man dafür einen Doktortitel haben und das ist so an gewissen Tagungen ist das schon so die Erwartung.
Und andererseits ist gerade so das Lernen im Netz, das steht dem eigentlich recht stark entgegen,
dass ich finde, das ist keine … ja diese Form der Qualifikation ist eigentlich etwas, was ich ideologisch gar nicht mehr so ganz nachvollziehen kann,
weshalb man das macht und ich stehe dann so wie in beiden Bereichen bisschen mit je einem Fuß oder einem Bein.
Und das ist jetzt kein großes Problem, aber das ist für mich so ein bisschen typisch für die Position, in der diese Bildungsdebatte im Moment gerade ist,
dass wir so ein altes etabliertes System haben mit bestimmten Qualifikationen, mit auch einem bestimmten Verteilschlüssel für Reputation.
Und wir haben ein neues System, das Aufmerksamkeit, Wahrnehmung und Wertschätzung auch auf ganz andere Art und Weise verteilen kann.
Und ja das ist dann auch, da gibt es sehr starke kulturelle Unterschiede, wie stark jetzt Bildungsinstitutionen gegenüber dieser Netzdynamik auch aufgeschlossen und auch daran interessiert sind oder nicht.
Jetzt haben wir ja hier, also in diesem Format, sehr oft so die deutsche Perspektive eingenommen,
da wir jetzt gerade aber viel über Schulen reden, muss ich vielleicht erst mal nachfragen, wo lässt sich denn das schweizer und das deutsche System vergleichen
und wo gibt es vielleicht ganz eklatante Unterschiede, die für die weitere Diskussion relevant sein könnten, soweit du weißt?
Ja, also natürlich gibt es so in den Feinheiten, also wie nennt man diese Dinge, da gibt es natürlich ganz große Unterschiede,
auch zwischen den einzelnen Bundesländern ja.
Und die zwei wichtigsten Unterschiede, würde ich sagen, ist, dass die Maturaquote, das ist Abitur, die ist in der Schweiz sehr sehr tief,
also das heißt, so um 20% machen Abitur, das heißt, das Gymnasium ist wirklich eine Elite.
Also es gibt eine Intelligenzforscherin an der ETH Zürich, Frau Stern, und die sagt, eigentlich sollten so die intelligentesten 16% ungefähr ans Gymnasium.
Das ist ihre Vorstellung, wofür diese Schule gemacht ist.
Es ist wirklich eigentlich Begabtenförderung.
Und das ist auch deshalb möglich, weil es eine sehr starke Berufsbildung gibt, also die meisten Jugendlichen gehen nach neun Jahren obligatorische Schulzeit
oder viele gehen in einen Betrieb und lernen dort eigentlich ein Handwerk oder ihren Beruf und gehen nebenher noch in die Schule.
Und das hat ein sehr hohes Ansehen, auch eine hohe gesellschaftliche Bedeutung in der Schweiz.
Und das ist so wie der eine Punkt und der zweite, dass du an einem Gymnasium, wo ich arbeite, die Lehrkräfte auch alle einen Master habe in einem Fach,
also sie haben nicht auf Lehramt studiert, sondern sind zunächst mal Biologin oder Germanist jetzt in meinem Fall
und dann haben sie auch noch eine Zusatzausbildung für die Lehrqualifikation abgeschlossen und das führt dazu,
dass viele Leute sich primär nicht als Lehrer betrachten, sondern zunächst einmal Fachpersonen sind in diesem Gebiet
und dann aber auch noch unterrichten.
Und das würde ich sagen ist ein bisschen so eine andere Stimmung und das hängt auch damit zusammen,
dass in vielen Fächern die Anstellungsbedingungen für Lehrkräfte gar nicht unbedingt so attraktiv sind.
Also es dauert sehr lange, bis man eine Stelle hat.
Und so was wie Verbeamtung und so weiter gibt es in dieser Form nicht.
Also man kann sagen, es ist eine andere Form auch von Selektion, wer da an Schulen arbeitet.
Das ist schon dadurch eine leicht andere Stimmung.
Und dadurch dass viele Kantone und auch Gemeinden in der Schweiz sehr föderalistisch arbeiten und vieles selbst bestimmen können,
gibt es weniger zentralistische Steuerung der Schulen.
Also es gibt kein Zentralabitur beispielsweise, es gibt auch wenig Vorschriften, die jetzt von einem Amt oder einem Kultusministerium an Schulen ergeben,
sondern die Schulen finden zunächst einmal eigene Lösungen.
Das zeigt sich auch darin, dass die Schulleitungen für Anstellungen zuständig sind.
Also sie wählen die Leute, die bei ihnen arbeiten, selbst aus und das ist schon in vielen Bereichen eine andere Vorstellung
Ich kann es vielleicht am Datenschutz ausführen, gestern hat der Datenschützer im Kanton Zürich ein großes Interview gegeben in der NZZ und gesagt,
ja WhatsApp an Schulen einsetzen geht rechtlich überhaupt nicht, das liegt nicht drin und trotzdem läuft das an jeder schweizer Schule.
Benutzen die Lehrer WhatsApp und das interessiert sie eigentlich ein bisschen weniger, ob das jetzt legal ist oder nicht,
weil sie auch nicht so Angst haben vor rechtlichen Konsequenzen.
Das ist schon, das nehme ich so in der deutschen Diskussion sehr stark wahr, dass man zunächst mal das Gesetz so hinkriegen muss,
bevor man an der Schule was machen kann und in der Schweiz gibt es an vielen Orten schon mehr die Stimmung,
wir machen mal was, wenn es funktioniert, dann machen wir das weiter.
Und ob das jetzt beim Amt genau geklärt ist, ob das so funktioniert oder nicht, das interessiert uns jetzt primär mal nicht.
Wir müssen nicht zuerst eine Bewilligung einholen, sondern wir suchen mal nach einer guten Lösung.
Also insgesamt führt das vielleicht ein bisschen zum innovativeren Klima.
Ich meine, die föderale Struktur gibt es ja in Deutschland auch, da ist ja Bildung Ländersache.
Aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, geht das hier noch sehr viel kleinteiliger, wie das ja eigentlich so oft in der Schweiz bei allem ist.
Ja, viele Länder sind ja so groß wie Schweiz selbst und die Schweiz ist dann noch aufgeteilt in die Sprachregionen,
wo es nochmals unterschiedliche Kulturen gibt, deshalb es ist schon viel kleinteiliger, ja.
Jetzt hast du ja ein paar Bücher geschrieben und im Vorgespräch klang schon an, naja Bücher sind ja eigentlich mehr abgeschriebene Blogbeiträge.
Nichtsdestotrotz gab es die, ein Buch zur Benutzung von SocialMedia in der Schule, also SocialMedia und wie man sozusagen konkret auch da mit verschiedenen Sachen umgehen sollte.
Warum schreibt man dann Bücher, wenn man eigentlich in Digitalien zuhause ist?
Ja das macht man natürlich auch wieder für diese Reputationsverteilung, die es in einer anderen Welt noch gibt.
Also wo man dann durchaus Publikationslisten vielleicht mal braucht oder wo man gewissen Leuten halt Eindruck machen kann,
wenn man sagt, ich habe ein Buch geschrieben, während, ich bin Blogger oder ich schreibe was ins Netz,
das ist ja mehr dann so, das kann irgendwie jeder oder so oder das ist sogar noch eher minderwertigere Form von Publikationen.
Und dass man wie zeigen kann, ja ich bin seriös, ich setze mich ernsthaft mit diesen Dingen auseinander,
dafür kann man das schon benutzen.
Und es ist andererseits aber auch natürlich eine Möglichkeit, einen größeren Bogen zu schlagen.
Diese Blogverläufe oder diese Verlinkungen, das hat ja so was rizomartiges, das ist so ein Wurzelgewächs,
wo man irgendwo einen Eingang findet und irgendwo kommt man wieder raus.
Und bei einem Buch gibt es ein Anfang und ein Ende und eine Struktur und das tut dann bei gewissen Themen schon gut,
um auch zu merken, also ich habe dann bei einigen Themen gemerkt, in dieser Auslegeordnung, das ist so wie ein Gebiet, wo ich mich noch nicht so gut auskenne,
da müsste ich jetzt auch mal sehen, was läuft da, was kann man machen.
Und wo ich dann merke, ja da habe ich vielleicht auch etwas Nachholbedarf, da müsste ich mal auch ein Projekt dazu durchführen,
um das glaubwürdig auch vertreten zu können oder um darüber was sagen zu können.
Und das hat schon auch geholfen, um die Dinge dann ja wirklich aufs Papier zu bringen, um es vielleicht mal so zu sagen.
Aber andererseits gibt es dann immer so diese zeitliche Verzögerung, dass man sagt, wenn ich ein Buch abgeschlossen habe,
dann ist das Thema für mich schon 1-2 Jahre zurück und ich bin schon an ganz anderen Fragen, und müsste dann,
um das Marketing vielleicht machen zu können, wieder über die Dinge sprechen, die mich vor einer bestimmten Weile interessiert haben.
Und da ist natürlich die Diskussion im Netz viel viel dynamischer und schneller auch. Und das ist manchmal gut,
aber manchmal natürlich auch, das gehört zur Expertise dazu, dass man gewisse Dinge vertieft und eine Gesamtschau betreibt
und deswegen finde ich es nicht so schlecht, das ist so ein bisschen dialektisch.
Also man schreibt ins Netz und formt das dann wieder in Bücher um.
Und andererseits profitieren die Bücher von diesen Diskussionen im Netz.
Ich glaube, das ist schon kein schlechter Modus dann in der Gesamtschau.
Rizomartig, das finde ich ein schönes Bild, dieses Geflecht, was man so im Netz ablegt und was ja auch davon lebt,
dass es sich mit anderen Dingen eigentlich vernetzt.
So das Buch steht ja dann, klar man hat eine Quellenliste, eine Referenzliste, aber man geht ja nicht bei Seite 35 dann gleich los und holt sich das andere Buch,
was gerade erwähnt wurde, liest das erst mal, um dann wieder weiterzulesen, was ja im Netz durchaus reinkommt.
Das heißt weniger interaktiv, schreibt man dann auch anders?
Um so ein Buch zu schreiben?
Ja, also ist das sozusagen eine andere Schreiben, als man sie jetzt im Blog verwendet?
Ja das kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich sehr auf die persönliche Herangehensweise an.
Da gibt es ja in der Fachliteratur verschiedene Schreibtypen, die unterschieden werden und ich schreibe jetzt nicht so anders,
als wenn ich einen Blogartikel schreibe, sondern es ist mehr so, dass ich halt mal ein Inhaltsverzeichnis  festlege
und dann versuche, die Lücken zu füllen, die noch nicht geschrieben sind.
Und ich mache es dann auch häufig so, dass ich zu gewissen Themen fast Grundlagenartikel dazu schreibe,
dass ich mal auch das auf dem Blog publiziere, vielleicht nicht als ganzes Kapitel, sondern so in Auszügen,
die mir jetzt besonders, wo ich mich frage, wie sind dann die Reaktionen darauf, trägt das oder muss ich da noch was verbessern?
Und danach mir ansehe, welches Feedback ich bekomme.
Aber eigentlich, die Leute, die jetzt regelmäßig meinen Blog lesen, die werden in meinen Büchern nicht sehr viel neues erfahren,
sondern es wie als Gesamtpaket dann so erhalten.
Ja das Publikum sind schon die Leute, die die Blogs eben nicht lesen oder nicht regelmäßig da draufgehen.
Und ist das Feedback darauf auch ein anderes?
Ja, das Feedback auf einzelne Netztexte ist feiner und oft direkter und das führt dann mehr zu einer Diskussion,
während das Buch dann immer so als Gesamtwerk auch gewürdigt wird.
Und das vielleicht etwas paradoxe daran ist, dass ich eigentlich Sachbücher selten ganz lese.
Ich lese dann immer nur Auszüge aus den Sachbüchern, weil ich sie auch so ansehe, dass Sachbücher eigentlich immer eine Mogelpackung sind,
weil man eigentlich vielleicht 15-20 Seiten hat, die wirklich gut sind und man baut das dann aus zu einem ganzen Buch.
Und trotzdem erwartet man dann vielleicht von Leuten, dass sie das eigene Buch auch ganz gelesen haben,
was natürlich dann also als Haltung völlig verständlich ist, dass sie dann auch nur einzelne Teile daraus lesen.
Und das Feedback, also ich erhalte oft so Leute, die mich halt dann einladen, auch wieder in bestimmte Workshops
oder mich beiziehen für Beratungen und da merke ich dann schon, die haben das Buch auch mit einem ganz spezifischen Interesse gelesen,
die stellen es dann einfach in ihren Kontext und nehmen daraus, was sie jetzt für diesen Kontext benutzen können.
Das ist auch okay?
Das ist eine Form des Transfers, der ja immer auch nötig ist bei diesen Formen von Wissensarbeit.
Kommen wir mal zur Schule.
Ich habe es ja eingangs schon gesagt, du bist Lehrer, also aus diesen Studien heraus ist jetzt eine Deutschlehrertätigkeit bei herabgefallen,
aber auch eine Tätigkeit hier an der Uni.
mhm (bejahend)
Wie teilt sich das auf?
Na ich bin so ungefähr die Hälfte der Woche, also ich bin auch so für 50% Angestellter der Schule.
Ich habe dort drei Klassen, die ich in Deutsch unterrichte.
Und an der Uni bilde ich angehende Deutschlehrerinnen und Deutschlehrer aus.
Die sind zu einem Studienseminar und kommen auch zu mir an die Schule, schauen zu, halten eigene Lektionen.
Und ich unterrichte sie auch in der Frage, wie funktioniert denn heute Deutschunterricht?
Was muss man dazu können?
Welche Kompetenz müssen sie sich aneignen?
Es ist eine sehr praxisorientierte Ausbildung auch.
Also die, die du letztlich auch selber genossen hast vorher.
Genau.
Um überhaupt erst in diese Lehramtssituation zu kommen.
Wie gestaltet sich denn dann der Deutschunterricht konkret, wenn man jetzt mal die digitale Brille aufsetzt?
Also du hast ja dann den traditionellen Weg selber wahrscheinlich beigebracht bekommen, der noch nicht sehr digital geprägt war
und hast jetzt quasi die Textadventure- und Amazon-Rezensions-Erfahrungen da mit einfließen lassen.
Was war denn vorher und was hat sich dann sozusagen in der eigenen Auseinandersetzung aus deiner Perspektive daraus dann entwickelt?
Sagen wir, Deutschunterricht ist für mich etwas geworden, was man vielleicht auch Kulturwissenschaft nennen könnte.
Ich habe nur Schülerinnen im Kurzzeitgymnasium, das heißt die sind so 14-16, wenn sie zu mir in die Schule kommen
und bleiben dann bis sie 18-20 sind.
Und in dieser Phase können sie natürlich schon so gewisse Grundfertigkeiten, die bringen sie mit.
Ich muss jetzt nicht irgendwie Lesen und Schreiben unterrichten, sondern ich kann davon ausgehen, dass sie sich schon mit gewissen Dingen auseinandersetzen können.
Und da geht es darum, natürlich einer bestimmten Form von Kultur zu begegnen.
Gewisse Fremdheitserfahrungen auch reflektieren zu können.
Sinnebenen zu erschließen in Texten, die zunächst sehr unverständlich erscheinen, und Strategien zu haben, wie reagiere ich darauf,
wie formuliere ich auch meine eigenen Gedanken.
Und da kann man sagen, dass sich viele dieser Tätigkeiten halt heute auch im Netz abspielen, dass es oft auch im Netz Texte sind, die gelesen werden
oder die verfasst werden und das ist etwas, was der traditionelle Deutschunterricht sehr stark ausblendet.
Also er tut so, als wäre er der Deutschunterricht von vor 50 Jahren und das zeigt sich einerseits ein bisschen an den Texten, die gelesen werden,
also man tut dann so, als ob die Belletristik, die vor 50 Jahren noch eine ganz andere gesellschaftliche Funktion gehabt hat,
als ob das heute immer noch so wäre wie damals.
Das heißt, man blendet digitale Texte, wie jetzt Computerspiele oder Fernsehserien oder solche Dinge, dass heute viele Leute Erzählungen in diesen Formaten genießen,
und gar nicht in Romanen, das blendet man sehr stark aus.
Und das ist so ein bisschen das, was ich jetzt für das zeitgemäße Lesen und Schreiben sehr wichtig finde, dass man bemerkt, dass es halt auch im Netz stattfindet.
Man muss jetzt nicht sagen, das ist ausschließlich im Netz, aber das ist gerade auch beim Schreiben sehr wichtig,
ich habe es jetzt für das Lesen schon ein bisschen dargestellt, beim Schreiben ist es halt eben auch so, wenn ich in ein Blog schreibe,
das klar ist, das gibt so einen Feedback-Loop, ich überarbeite meine Texte, ich kann die irgendwie wieder umformen, und oft ist so die klassische Aufsatzlehre ist natürlich daran orientiert,
ich schreibe einen Text und der ist dann fertig und dann wird er bewertet.
Und das ist etwas, was heute in der aktuellen Textpraxis recht absurd ist, dass ich alleine einen Text schreibe, ohne dass ich jemanden beiziehe,
dass ich keine digitalen Hilfsmittel dazu verwende.
Also solche Dinge, da stößt so der klassische Deutschunterricht so an gewisse Relevanzgrenzen würde ich sagen, wo man sich fragen kann,
ist das, was man hier eigentlich tut, ist das überhaupt noch gesellschaftlich von Bedeutung?
Und deshalb scheint es mir wichtig, über zeitgemäße Formen im Deutschunterricht auch nachzudenken und zu sehen, was man da machen kann.
Also sowohl was das Lesen oder ich sage mal das Konsumieren betrifft, weil wenn Fernsehserien jetzt quasi auch als Kulturquelle anerkannt werden und mit in den Unterricht reingebracht werden,
dann liest man es ja noch nicht mal, sondern man schaut es sich an oder hört zu.
Ja, also klar, ich meine, im Unterricht das ist ein Punkt, den ich mit den Klassen häufig bespreche,
es geht natürlich nicht darum, dass sie die Dinge, die sie für ihren privaten Genuss lesen oder eben auch schauen oder spielen,
dass sie das jetzt eins zu eins im Unterricht machen, das ist dann so ein Missverständnis.
Sondern ich nehme dann natürlich bei den Computerspielen Autorenspiele und da geht es darum, das sind häufig so Independent-Formate,
die nicht immer so einfach anschlussfähig sind an das, was die Schülerinnen und Schüler in ihrem Alltag spielen.
Und es geht dann darum, dieser Herausforderung zu begegnen und zu sehen, ja was ist jetzt damit gemeint?
Oder was macht das mit mir, wenn ich jetzt das lese?
Genauso wie der klassische Literaturunterricht auch nicht die Bücher nimmt, die Fantasy-Romane, die sie in der Freizeit lesen und gerne lesen,
die liest man dann ja nicht im Unterricht, sondern man liest Dinge, die sich ein Stück weit auch davon abgrenzen oder die die Lesekompetenz erweitern können.
Und so ist das natürlich auch im digitalen Raum.
Was wäre da mal so ein Beispiel für so ein Computerspiel, was diese Relevanz erzielt, also Autorenspiel, was heißt das genau?
Ja ein größeres Projekt habe ich zu Sunset gemacht, das ist ein Spiel, das spielt in Südamerika in einer Diktatur und man spielt es eigentlich aus der Perspektive einer Putzkraft,
die in einem Haus eines Mitarbeiters dieses Diktators angestellt ist und dann so schrittweise eigentlich erfährt, was da abläuft.
Das sind massive Menschenrechtsverletzungen und der Bruder dieser Putzkraft ist revolutionär.
Also man merkt dann aus verschiedenen Perspektiven, was da passiert und gleichzeitig kann man eigentlich nichts anderes tun als putzen.
Also man hat nicht die Möglichkeiten jetzt, einen Fall aufzuklären oder irgendwie rumzuballern oder so was, sondern man kann nur sehr repetitive, fast sinnlose Tätigkeiten tun,
die eigentlich auch im Interesse des Unterdrückers sind und das ist dann natürlich eine Parabel auf so bisschen die Wohlstandsgesellschaft,
die die Probleme zwar sieht, aber eigentlich nichts dagegen tun kann und so repetitiven Unsinn eigentlich macht und das dann zu merken, ist schon eine Herausforderung.
Also zunächst muss man das Spiel auch ertragen und da weiterspielen.
Und solche Spiele gibt es dann natürlich recht viele, die dann auch über Steam sehr gut greifbar sind.
Ich versuche da, verschiedene Dinge zu tun, wo die Schülerinnen und Schüler auch weiterdenken können und die Spiele auch ein bisschen hinterfragen können.
Ein anderes klassisches Beispiel ist The Stanley Parabel, das ist so ein Klassiker der Spielkultur, wo schon nur die Frage, wer erzählt eigentlich dieses Spiel, ist sehr sehr schwierig zu beantworten
und man kann dann sehr gut zu klassischen Erzählanalysen übergehen, aber das Spiel lebt auch von der Repetition.
Es ist eine Aussage über die aktuelle Arbeitswelt und das sind Dinge, die sehr klar deutlich machen, wie differenziert und vielschichtig solche digitale Literatur auch ist.
Und die Leute, die denken, ja das sind jetzt einfache Serien oder einfache Spiele, die eigentlich narrativ nicht viel hergeben,
die haben sich einfach zu wenig intensiv damit beschäftigt.
Und wie kommt das bei den Schülern an?
Ja, es ist nicht so einfach, wie man denken könnte.
Zunächst einmal ist es technisch ein bisschen eine Herausforderung, also man muss dann immer erklären, wie installiert man das,
man muss sie davon überzeugen, dass so ein Spiel auch was kostet oder kosten darf.
Also bei mir ist es so, am Gymnasium ist die Regel, dass eigentlich die Eltern die Schulmaterialen bezahlen müssen, also auch die Bücher.
Also wenn ich einen Roman lese, dann bestelle ich den und die Klassen kaufen den.
Und wenn das so 10 Franken kostet ein Taschenbuch zu kaufen, dann finde ich, ich kann auch mal 5-10 Franken für ein Spiel einfordern,
aber das braucht dann schon ein bisschen Überzeugungskraft.
Und dann gibt es auch solche, die gar nicht spielen beispielsweise, die so auch ganz anders aufgewachsen sind und dann muss man versuchen,
ja ich mache das dann gerne als Gespräch und ihnen Raum zu geben, diese teilweise ablehnende Haltung auch auszudrücken,
während andere sehr begeistert sind und das sehr gerne machen und das auch gut können.
Das ist nicht immer ganz gleich.
Viele können sich ja auch für Buchlesen nicht begeistern.
Genau, aber da haben sie halt schon in den neun Jahren Deutschunterricht, bevor sie zu mir in die Schule gekommen sind,
irgendwie Schulsozialisation gelernt, dass Buchlesen irgendwie in der Schule eine Bedeutung hat und dass es nichts bringt zu sagen,
ich lese nicht gerne, weil die Lehrer sagen, lesen ist total wichtig.
Aber wenn jetzt der eine seltsame Deutschlehrer kommt und sagt, wir spielen jetzt ein Computerspiel, dann ist es halt mehr eine Abweichung von dem Muster, das sie kennen.
Und das monieren sie dann vielleicht etwas stärker.
Aber es hat auch positive Auswirkungen?
Ja auf jeden Fall.
Also ich finde, die Resultate, was dann am Schluss rauskommt und was sie auch in eigenen Reflexionen schreiben, das ist etwas, was mir immer auch wieder andere Perspektiven öffnet,
wo ich denke, da findet dann auch stärker ein echter Dialog statt, als jetzt bei einem Buch, wo im Netz häufig schon steht, wie das jetzt zu verstehen ist
oder was man jetzt dazu sagen könnte und alles wurde irgendwie von schlauen Leuten dazu schon gedacht
und das ist bei diesen Computerspielen teilweise etwas anders und ja…
Weil sich solche Rezensionen einfach nicht finden oder weil sie auch so nicht zu generieren sind, weil eigentlich diese interaktive Erfahrung eines solchen Spiels auch nochmal einen eigenen Wert darstellt?
Genau, also man spricht auch ein bisschen von Werteerziehung.
Das ist ein Wort, das ich jetzt nicht so besonders mag, weil es so vorgibt, man würde ein bestimmtes Wertekorsett einfach den Schülerinnen und Schülern überstülpen.
Aber bei Werteerziehung geht es darum auch, eigene Werte zu reflektieren und sich die bewusst zu machen und Entscheidungen fällen zu können.
Und da gibt es die Tradition, die sagt, das kann man bei Literatur sehr gut, weil man eigentlich eigene Entscheidungen fällen kann im Leserprozess,
aber diese Entscheidungen sind ja häufig sehr stark moderiert von der Erzählstruktur her.
Also es ist zum Beispiel klar, wer die Identifikationsfigur ist, also es kann niemand Harry Potter lesen und sagen,
ahja Snape das bin ich jetzt in dieser Geschichte und ich fühle jetzt mit dem mit, das geht nicht auf.
Und bei Computerspielen das ist schon eine Debatte, wie weit da Entscheidungen möglich sind, aber ich kann zumindest sagen,
ich kann das Spiel auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise spielen und ich erhalte eine Reaktion, es passiert etwas, es hat Konsequenzen in diesem Spiel,
wenn ich mich auf eine gewisse Art und Weise entscheide.
Und wenn ich sage, für eine Wertereflexion ist die Möglichkeit einer Entscheidung ganz wichtig, dann ist natürlich diese Erfahrung im Spiel etwas anderes
als wenn ich einfach einen Text lese, der jetzt in der Struktur schon da liegt.
Und natürlich kann ich im produktiven Literaturunterricht, wenn Texte weitergeschrieben werden oder umgeschrieben werden,
dann kann ich auch dazu kommen, dass Schülerinnen und Schüler Entscheidungen fällen müssen und auch dafür eintreten müssen,
aber das ist dann im didaktischen Arrangement nicht unbedingt schon in der Vorlage vorgegeben.
Und da kann man vielleicht noch anknüpfen, ist natürlich auch spannend, Vermittlungsaufgaben zu machen, dann zu sagen,
ja was hat es jetzt mit diesen Let’sPlays auf sich, die ja viele, vor allem die jungen Männer schauen die sehr sehr gerne auf YouTube, und dann zu sagen, ja weshalb?
Versuch mal zu erklären deinen Eltern, deinen Großeltern, weshalb schaust du das gerne, wenn jetzt einfach ein Spieler ein Spiel spielt?
Weshalb spielst du nicht lieber das Spiel, statt jemandem zuzusehen?
Und da hat es häufig auch damit zu tun, dass das Spiel so gegen den Strich gespielt wird, dass man versucht, so eine Experimentalanordnung zu finden,
was passiert, wenn ich das und das mache?
Und ja ich finde, da sind einfach reflexiv Dinge möglich, die stärker auch von der Alltagspraxis ausgehen, die dann wieder zurückschlagen auf das,
was die Jugendlichen ohnehin tun, wo sie sich bewusst werden, ah ich tue das aus diesen und diesen Gründen oder das macht das und das mit mir
und das ist so mit der Kanonliteratur etwas schwieriger.
Also bei den Computerspielen, warum sich Leute so was als Let’sPlay anschauen, antworte ich immer, warum gehen Leute in Fußballstadien?
Ja kann man natürlich.
Wobei die spielen das Spiel ja auch nicht.
Genau, das ist sicher eine sehr gute Antwort, dass es einfach Leute sind, die sehr gut spielen können.
Aber es hat natürlich noch so ein bisschen den Comedy-Aspekt, also dass die dann häufig auch sehr lustig das Ganze darstellen,
dazu glaube ich auch, dass sie an Bereiche kommen, das ist beim Fußball auch so, dass sie Dinge können, die ich selbst jetzt einfach nicht kann, wenn ich Fußball spiele
und jetzt möchte ich mal sehen, was passiert, wenn jemand einen Freistoß aus 40 Metern aufs Tor zielen kann.
Genau, das ist eine sehr gute Analogie.
Also wenn man jetzt digitales … also ich will es jetzt gar nicht so auf Medien oder irgendwie so was unterbrechen,
ich finde eigentlich gerade diese Erfahrungswelt mit dem Spiel jetzt sehr interessant als Idee, zumal es ja auch – ich will es jetzt nicht überhöhen -
aber das macht jetzt gerade auf mich so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass man eigentlich so auf die nächste Metaebene bei der Betrachtung von einem Thema stößt,
da man ja eigentlich die Nacherzählung einer Perspektive oder die Schilderung einer Perspektive, was jetzt so der klassische Text, das Buch, ist,
ich habe mir darüber Gedanken gemacht und das ist das, was ich sehe, eigentlich durch diese Interaktivität auf so eine Ebene hebt, wo man sagt,
jetzt kannst du in diesem Ereignisraum quasi die Erfahrung, wenn auch virtualisiert, selber machen und dadurch eigentlich erst mal ganz andere Verläufe erzielen,
die natürlich in einem Spiel auch in gewisser Hinsicht vorbestimmt sind, aber eben beeinflussbar sind zu einem bestimmten Grad,
wo ja dann sozusagen auch diese Eigenerfahrung des, oh Gott jetzt passiert das mit mir, im Sinne von meines virtuellen Spielers an der Stelle.
Ist das an sich schon mal jetzt eine ganz neue Qualität oder greife ich jetzt zu weit?
Ja ich würde sagen, eigentlich im Literaturunterricht möchte man an denselben Punkt kommen, dass ich sage, ja es gibt einen Text,
den kann ich analysieren und beschreiben und gleichzeitig ist der Text auch ein Erfahrungsraum und ich kann beschreiben, was in meiner Interaktion mit dem Text passiert.
Aber das ist viel schwieriger, weil der Text sehr starke Angebote oder Anreize schafft, ihn auf die richtige Art und Weise zu lesen
und das sich dann darauf einlassen, beim einem Computerspiel passiert das häufiger, dass die Interaktion dann trotzdem stattfindet und ich mal ein bisschen experimentiere,
was kann ich damit machen oder wie kann ich mich durch diese Spielwelt bewegen, was jetzt bei einem Text, wenn ich jetzt, sage wir mit der Abschlussklasse,
wenn ich einen Kafka-Text lese, dann sagen viele einfach, nein also hören Sie mal, dieser Käfer, was soll das?
Da habe ich einfach das Buch zugeklappt und was anderes gemacht.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass die Erfahrung einfach gar nicht mehr gemacht wird, sondern es bleibt dann nur so die Verweigerung oder die Überwindung,
den Text irgendwie Wort für Wort noch zu entziffern, und das glaube ich fällt bei einem Spiel etwas einfacher, sich auch wirklich auf fremde Erfahrungen einzulassen
und da mit zu gehen, als das jetzt bei Literatur der Fall ist.
Kommen dann auch kafkaeske Spiele zum Einsatz, wo man …
Ja genau, viele Spiele sind natürlich in dieser Form auch kafkaesk, das ist schon so.
Allein schon, weil man nicht in der Lage ist, sie zu Ende zu spielen.
Genau.
Wenn man jetzt das mal weiterspinnt, also man bringt halt Geräte mit rein, dann stellt sich auch immer wieder die Frage, wo kommen denn diese Geräte eigentlich her?
Und das ist ja auch ein verständlicher Einwand, wie ich finde, dass man dieses, okay wir machen jetzt irgendwie digital, aber womit machen wir das denn jetzt eigentlich?
Wie organisiert sich denn das bei dir in der Klasse, dass Computer benutzt werden, welche Geräte werden denn genutzt, wem gehören die, wer kauft die?
Kann man sich da irgendwie auf Modelle einigen?
Kompatibilitätsfragen sind ja eigentlich ganz praktische Probleme, die man eigentlich hat, wenn man das Ganze digitalisieren möchte.
Ja, es ist so, dass an der alten Schule, an der ich war bis letztes Jahr, da war eigentlich bring-your-own-device schon eingeführt.
Das heißt, die Schülerinnen und Schüler haben Geräte mitgebracht.
Wenn ich in Deutschland die Bilder zeige, die Leute fragen dann immer, wie kommt das, dass zwei Drittel so einen Apple Laptop mitbringen?
Aber so ist die Situation ungefähr in der Schweiz, dass die Eltern zumindest denken, also es ist jetzt wirklich wichtig für die Ausbildung, das brauchst du
und viele sich das auch leisten können.
Also die bringen so state of the art Laptops mit.
Und ich jetzt an der neuen Schule gibt es das noch nicht so formell, dass das den Eltern gesagt wird, aber wenn ich sage,
bringen Sie mal Laptops mit, dann ist es schon so, die Hälfte der Klasse kann problemlos morgen einen Laptop mitbringen in den Unterricht, vielleicht auch zwei Drittel.
Also ich kann schon so auf die private Geräteausstattung zurückgreifen einerseits.
Aber was ist mit dem anderen Drittel?
Ja, dann muss ich natürlich … wenn das nicht offizielle Doktrin ist, dann muss ich eine Form finden, in der es natürlich nicht alle Geräte braucht,
oder in denen man dann zusammen arbeiten kann oder sich was ansehen kann, das ist so das eine.
Das andere ist natürlich, dass die dann vielleicht auch aufs Handy ausweichen können.
Ich mach dann natürlich nichts, wenn ich ein Gerät habe, habe ich einen Vorteil oder das bringt mir irgendwie eine bessere Note oder so was,
das ist nicht die Idee, sondern man kann dann wirklich auch zusammen was machen.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel dieses, wie heißt jetzt dieses Keep Talking and Nobody Explodes, oder so ähnlich heißt das Spiel.
Das ist ein interaktives Computerspiel, bei dem jemand einen Laptop hat und darauf sieht man eine Bombe, die man entschärfen muss
und die andere Person hat ein komplexes Manual, das eigentlich erklärt, wie man die Bombe entschärfen muss.
Und man darf gar nicht auf den Bildschirm sehen, sondern ich müsste jetzt dir erklären, wie du auf deinem Computer die Bombe entschärfen kannst.
Das ist ein sehr tolles Spiel, bei dem es ganz stark um Kommunikation geht, also wie organisieren wir diesen Kommunikationsprozess, dass das funktioniert.
Und da kann ich gut machen, zwei Personen sind an einem Computer, zwei haben das Manual vor sich ausgedruckt, also das muss man auch ausgedruckt vor sich haben,
und dann braucht es für vier Personen einen Laptop.
Also das ist so eine Form, wo ich sagen kann, da haben alle was davon, wenn die Geräte da sind, aber es braucht jetzt nicht 100% Abdeckung.
Und viele Dinge kann man tatsächlich am Handy machen und da gibt es natürlich immer wieder so Ärgernisse,
also in Zürich gibt es ein Startup, das macht so Literaturrundgänge durch die Stadt und die sind kostenlos, man kann sich die App runterladen
und dann kann man ganz verschiedene Themen, die mit Literatur und der Stadt Zürich zu tun haben, kann man erkunden auf so zweistündigen Spaziergängen.
Und das ist eigentlich recht ideal, weil die Schule ist in der Stadt und ich kann direkt losgehen, wenn ich eine Doppelstunde Deutsch habe,
dann reicht das eigentlich aus, um das zu machen, aber die App funktioniert nur auf iOS.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte eigentlich für alle Schülerinnen und Schüler ein Apple Handy.
Und das schaffe ich dann tatsächlich nicht, das ist nicht so einfach, dass das dann wirklich alle organisieren können,
weil es wirklich Familien gibt, die arbeiten mit anderen Systemen oder anderen Geräten.
Und das ist dann schon etwas ärgerlich, wenn es so diese Abhängigkeit von bestimmten Plattformen, von bestimmter Software gibt.
Manchmal braucht es schon etwas Fantasie oder Zugang zu Dingen.
Und meist, wenn ich jetzt sage, so 90% der Dinge, die ich im Unterricht mache, die sind so abgestützt, dass es eigentlich plattform- und auch geräteunabhängig einfach funktioniert.
Also sagen wir, das häufigste, was ich mache, sind so Edu-Pads, wo einfach gemeinsam Leute einen Text schreiben.
Und das geht mit dem Handy, das geht mit dem Computer, das spielt gar keine Rolle, womit man dann letztlich arbeitet.
Und das ist schon eigentlich woran ich mich sehr stark orientiere, dass es unter den gegebenen Bedingungen einfach funktioniert.
Und es ist nicht so zu Ärgernissen kommt.
Ich glaube, da wurde ganz viel kaputt gemacht, natürlich die Zeit, wo es noch so Computerräume gab an Schulen.
Und da bin ich oft mit Klassen hingegangen und hatte große Pläne, wie gedacht, ja heute machen wir mal das.
Also so am Anfang sehr idealistisch, jetzt schreiben sich alle mal eine Homepage.
Irgendwie habe ich was eingerichtet und jetzt machen alle so ihre eigene Homepage.
Und dann war das so, die haben die Geräte hochgefahren und dann schon bei dreien klappte das nicht und dann haben die mich gerufen,
ich ging dahin, versuchte das Problem zu lösen, merkte irgendwie, das geht wirklich nicht oder da ist der Monitor kaputt
oder irgendjemand hat da Cola ausgeschüttet über die Tastatur, jetzt müssen wir das hinkriegen.
Und dann gab es fünf, die waren dann schon irgendwie in diesem Programm drin, hatten eine sachliche Frage, also ich habe da mal was programmiert,
aber beim Header da ist jetzt das und das, wie muss ich das korrigieren?
Und ich hätte eigentlich an 15 Orten gleichzeitig sein müssen und am Schluss ist niemand fertig geworden, alle waren frustriert,
ich war total gestresst, total frustriert.
Und daraus habe ich wieder den Schluss gezogen, so dürfte es eigentlich nicht laufen.
Also es müsste immer möglich sein, dass alle irgendwie weiter machen können oder es so einfach ist, dass es einfach null technische Hürden gibt.
Also heute mache ich das meist so mit Core-Code oder ich schreibe einen Kurzlink an die Wandtafel und dann muss es einfach funktionieren.
Und das klappt jetzt heute, das ist oft viel einfacher, aber führt dazu, dass man sich halt ein bisschen beschränken muss
oder einen gewissen Minimalismus auch haben muss und sagen muss, ja es gibt vielleicht diese sehr elaborierte Umgebung,
wo man noch ganz viele Dinge machen kann, aber ich nehme jetzt ganz bewusst einfach nur diese ZumPad und mach einfach damit.
Weil es wäre zwar schön, die Zusatzfunktionen zu haben, aber dann verliere ich jetzt wieder so und so viele Leute oder ich muss es ihn erklären,
dann nehme ich einfach die einfachste Möglichkeit.
Und das funktioniert jetzt aus meiner Sicht in den Schweizer Verhältnissen recht gut.
Also das heißt, die meisten Schülerinnen und Schüler haben auch ein Datenabo, also wenn jetzt mal WLAN nicht so gut funktioniert an der Schule,
dann können sie auch so direkt ins Netz oder sie machen sich dann gegenseitig so Hotspots auf und das mache ich auch und dann funktioniert es auch, wenn das WLAN mal recht langsam ist.
Aber eigentlich ist die Ausstattung jetzt an Schweizer Gymnasien schon so gut, dass man sagen kann, es gibt an allen Schulen eigentlich ein WLAN,
das mehr oder weniger funktioniert im Alltag, wenn jetzt nicht alle Klassen gleichzeitig was streamen oder so.
Heißt also im Umkehrschluss auch, die meisten arbeiten quasi mit ihrem eigenen Gerät und ich meine zumindest bei den Smartphones dürfte das ja relativ omnipräsent sein.
Laptops sind ja nochmal eine andere Geschichte, ist jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht so jedermanns Sache.
Es gibt glaube ich auch viele, die mit den Telefonen sehr viel besser umgehen können oder bzw. einfach nicht die Notwendigkeit sehen, jetzt irgendwie auf die großen Plattformen zu gehen.
Heißt ja auch, dass quasi so eine Dauerpräsenz dieser Geräte da ist.
Das ist ja so in dieser ganzen Debatte immer so eine beliebte Beschwerde, oh Gott wenn die Jugendlichen jetzt alle ihre Kommunikationsgeräte dabei haben,
die so 24/7 durch die Gegend funken, wie soll sich da überhaupt noch einer konzentrieren, da ist man ja permanent unterbrochen.
Da ist man in so einem multitasking-Modus.
Wie hat sich das entwickelt?
Ich meine, es ist ja durchaus ein nachvollziehbare Argument, ist das ein Problem oder ist das kein Problem oder ist das ein Problem, was man irgendwie handhaben kann?
Oder ist das vielleicht ein Problem, aber der Mehrwert überwiegt, was ist so das Zwischenergebnis der Volldigitalisierung?
Ja vielleicht muss ich sagen, ich habe es schon mit, sagen wir, sehr privilegierten Schülerinnen und Schülern zu tun, die auch in der Schule wirklich erfolgreich sind,
sonst wären sie nicht am Gymnasium.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt von meiner konkreten Unterrichtssituation ausgehe, dann ist mir völlig klar, da gibt es noch ganz ganz andere Situationen,
also das ist immer so das Brennpunkt-Schulen-Argument, dass man sagt, ja geh mal in so eine Schule und was du dort siehst,
da würdest du die Meinung komplett ändern.
Also man muss vielleicht sagen, das ist sicher nicht einheitlich.
Also ich habe kürzlich mit einem Freund gesprochen, der an einer Sekundarschule unterrichtet, so heißt es in der Schweiz,
das ist so eine Schule, wo man die ganze Bandbreite der Gesellschaft sieht und da haben sie Schüler, die jetzt aktuell nicht mehr zur Schule kommen,
teilweise wochen- und monatelang, weil sie einfach nur noch Fortnite spielen.
Also Fortnite ist so für sie wirklich ein Problem im Moment, mit dem Eltern sehr große Mühe haben.
Und natürlich, wenn man das jetzt aus allen Perspektiven ansieht, dann ist das meistens so, da sind die Eltern gerade in der Scheidung
oder es läuft sonst was einfach nicht gut zu Hause und das ist dann eigentlich mehr Ausdruck von diesem familiären Problem, also es ist genauso wie,
wenn Schüler jetzt einfach permanent kiffen oder wenn sie Alkoholprobleme haben oder so was, dann ist es ja auch meist Ausdruck von einem anderen Problem,
das auch noch dazukommt, es ist nicht einfach der Alkohol oder die Verfügbarkeit, die das auslösen.
Und trotzdem kann man sagen, ja das sind jetzt schon qualitativ sehr hochwertige Unterhaltungsangebote, die jetzt auch auf dem Handy verfügbar sind.
Also Fortnite spielen viele auch auf dem Handy, da brauche ich keinen Computer dazu oder keine Konsole.
Und lange Zeit habe ich gesagt, ja da müsst ihr halt einfach besseren Unterricht machen.
Wenn der Unterricht spannend ist, dann wird das funktionieren.
Und mittlerweile habe ich gemerkt, das ist sicher ein Fehlschluss, weil ich kann nicht Unterricht machen, der irgendwie spannender ist,
als das was Netflix oder die Computerspielindustrie anbietet, weil die einfach anders ticken.
Also es wäre so, wie wenn ich sagen würde, ja die Schulküche muss jetzt einfach besseres Mittagessen machen als McDonalds.
Das geht in diesem Alter … also besseres Essen als diese McDonalds Pommes Frites, das kann man für Jugendliche nicht machen, das geht gar nicht.
Und dann was macht man da?
Dann ist es sicher so, dass man sagen muss, das ist eine Realität.
Also wenn wir jetzt hier miteinander sprechen, sind auch mehrere Geräte in diesem Raum da und wir können trotzdem ein konzentriertes Gespräch führen.
Also irgendwie muss man als Erwachsener gelernt haben, wie geht man damit um, dass diese Möglichkeiten da sind, aber ich mich trotzdem konzentrieren muss.
Und da bin ich weiterhin überzeugt, da muss die Schule einen Beitrag leisten, aber auch natürlich eine Struktur bieten und ein Angebot machen.
Und das ist schon so, dass ich glaube, dass Rituale ganz wichtig sind, dass man in der Schule sagt, es gibt Phasen, da sind die Geräte einfach weg
und die stören nicht und da muss ich halt auch mal durchgreifen disziplinarisch und sagen, ja jetzt einfach weglegen oder ich nehme es mal für eine kurze Zeit weg.
Also nicht so wochenlang wegnehmen, sondern für diese Stunde legen sie es mal nach vorne und sie holen es dann nachher wieder ab.
Und dazu natürlich auch zeigen, was Möglichkeiten sind, um sich konzentrieren zu können.
Also ein Resultat von dem, was ich jetzt gemacht habe im letzten Semester, war, ich habe mit Sketchnotes gearbeitet, das ist natürlich so ein großer Trend im Moment
so in der digitalen Bildungslandschaft und gleichzeitig …
Also so ein grafisches Notieren von Inhalten.
Genau, ja. So Wissenslandkarten, sagt man auch, anlegen.
Und ich wollte, dass die Schülerinnen und Schüler eine Technik haben, mit der sie sich auch lernen zu fokussieren.
Und das scheint mir ganz wichtig zu sein, dass man sich auch praktisch fragen muss, ja wie macht man das, wie lernt man das überhaupt?
Und gestern hat gerade ein Schüler auf unserer Schulkonferenz, da war das Thema, weshalb gibt es so viele Schüler, die die Probezeit nicht bestehen?
Und dann haben viele Lehrkräfte gesagt, ja sie müssen halt lernen, sich besser vorzubereiten auf große Prüfungen, auch mal frühzeitig beginnen.
Und dann hat einer gesagt, aber Sie sagen uns gar nicht wie das geht, Sie sagen immer nur, das müssen wir können, aber wie geht das dann?
Und da denke ich sagt die Schule oft, ja man muss halt lernen sich zu fokussieren, obwohl diese Geräte da sind, aber wie lernt man das?
Das glaube ich, damit muss man sich stärker auseinandersetzen und da gibt es viele Leute an Schulen, die nehmen so eine Abkürzung und sagen,
ja wir verbieten jetzt einfach mal die Geräte oder wir beziehen die nicht mit ein und sie bilden sich dann ein, das Problem gelöst zu haben,
und vergessen, dass sobald diese Kinder und Jugendlichen in die Berufswelt gehen oder sobald sie zu Hause sind, dass die Geräte natürlich immer noch da sind
und niemand ihnen sagt, leg das Gerät mal zur Seite.
Und deshalb würde ich jetzt dafür plädieren weiterhin, die Schule muss diese Herausforderung annehmen und ganz konkrete Strategien auch zeigen,
wie Konzentration möglich ist, auch wenn wir diese vielen Reize nebeneinander haben oder diese vielen Angebote.
Mag jetzt vielleicht beim Deutschunterricht nicht so ganz das Thema sein, aber vielleicht in anderen Unterrichtsformen ist natürlich das Telefon auch der feuchte Traum des Spickzettelideals.
Inwiefern ist des quasi so das Telefon als Betrugsobjekt ein Problem?
Ja das ist auch so ein Meilenstein, sagen wir, in meiner Karriere als Experte für digitale Bildung.
Ich habe mal bei einem NZZ-Artikel mitgearbeitet, wo es darum ging, dass so dieses digitale Spicken.
Wo eigentlich zum ersten Mal wirklich klar geworden ist in den Medien, dass die Schülerinnen und Schüler mit so einer Chatgruppe währen der Prüfung so in Realtime sich die Lösungen zuschicken können.
Damit hat jetzt gar niemand gerechnet gehabt, dass das überhaupt möglich wäre.
Und mittlerweile haben fast alle Schulen so Kisten, wo bei Prüfungen die Handys rein müssen.
Und ich glaube, das funktioniert so mehr oder weniger gut.
Also ich meine, null Toleranz beim Spicken, das hat es noch nie gegeben, das mögen sich vielleicht einzelne Lehrerinnen und Lehrer einbilden,
aber ich würde dann natürlich wieder auf die Metaebene wechseln und ich sage dann immer so am Gymnasium,
ja wenn ihr eine Prüfung macht, bei der man spicken kann, dann ist die Prüfung einfach an sich schon nicht gymnasial.
Also egal welches Fach ich unterrichte, ich mache eigentlich immer Prüfungen, wo sie die Bücher und Unterlagen mitbringen sollen,
weil ich Fragen stelle, die gar nicht einfach eine Wiedergabe von dem sind, was irgendwo steht, sondern es ist eine Anwendung von dem, was irgendwo steht.
Und da gibt es natürlich viele Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die sagen, ja aber in meinem Fach geht das nicht.
Und ich glaube, dass es in vielen Fällen eine Ausrede ist, weil sie einfach sich das Leben etwas einfacher machen möchten,
weil sie nicht Argumente einfordern, sondern halt einfach so richtig/falsch Antworten auf gewisse Fragen und eben gar nicht aus dieser Anwendungsperspektive vielleicht darüber nachdenken.
Und lustigerweise sind das meistens dieselben Leute, nein das stimmt nicht, dass das Wissen alles über Google abfragbar ist,
das stimmt überhaupt nicht, dass das Wissen alles im Netz ist, aber bei meinen Prüfungen darf man nicht im Netz nachsehen,
weil sonst wäre es viel zu einfach.
Und das ist irgendwie eine kognitive Dissonanz, die sie so durchziehen, dass ich eigentlich finde, wenn eine Prüfung gerade Dinge abfragt,
die ich mit Google auch beantworten könnte, was soll das für eine Kompetenz sein, die ich damit nachweise?
Und wenn die Schule sich nur auf diesem Niveau bewegt, also wenn es keine Reflexion braucht, keine Beurteilung von einem Sachverhalt,
dann ist das eigentlich ein Spiel, was in einigen Jahren die Maschinen spielen werden, also das nichts so, was ist die Hauptstadt von irgendeinem Land,
das kann ich ja jetzt schon diese Siri- und Googleassistenten fragen und die geben mir die Antwort.
Und solche Fragen, finde ich, haben einfach in Prüfungen 2018 nichts mehr verloren.
Welche Fragen haben denn dann da was verloren?
Also muss man denn andere Sachen fragen?
Ja.
Andere Fähigkeiten herauskitzeln, und welche Fächer sehen sich denn eigentlich am meisten bedroht von den Spickmöglichkeiten?
Ja eine Diskussion, die sehr stark läuft, ist natürlich so die nach der Frage, muss man irgendwelches Wissen aufbauen oder Kompetenzen,
damit man sie dann danach anwenden kann?
Das ist etwas, was viele Leute sagen, die sich gegen diese Kritik wehren würden,
die sagen, ja du musst halt einfach zunächst mal Mathematik so lernen, damit du die Probleme auch lösen kannst.
Und es gab diese Woche einen Artikel von dem ETH-Bildungsforscher, der gesagt hat,
eigentlich braucht es backwards-engineering, das heißt, man muss zuerst eigentlich von der Anwendung ausgehen
und erst dann diesen Aufbau machen und das ist auch die Haltung, die ich eigentlich vertrete.
Also ich muss zuerst wissen, wozu muss ich überhaupt diese Rechenmöglichkeiten kennen, bevor ich sie lerne.
Also ich muss sie nicht abstrakt lernen, sondern immer in Bezug auf eine bestimmte Anwendung.
Und da gibt es natürlich auch didaktische Tradition, die das so machen, die davon ausgehen, also die beispielsweise das kleinste gemeinsame Vielfache,
der größte gemeinsame Teiler, das sind ja so wichtige Konzepte, das ist so 6./7. Klasse im Mathematikunterricht.
Und da könnte man jetzt einfach ein Rad hinstellen und sagen, ja das hat so eine Schaltung, die funktioniert so und so und jetzt ordne mal die Gänge,
welcher Gang ist denn der leichteste und welches der schwerste?
Und das ist kein so einfaches Problem, wie man weiß, wenn man schon mal mit so einem Rad gefahren ist und dafür braucht es natürlich dann diese Konzepte,
die man entdecken könnte, wenn man von einem Problem ausgeht.
Aber wenn sie einfach einem so hingeknallt werden, frontaler Mathematikunterricht, dann ist es eigentlich auch so ein Unterricht,
der unheimlich wichtig scheint, da sagen viele Leute, ja diese Konzepte im Mathematikunterricht, die muss man tatsächlich irgendwann mal gehört haben,
aber in der Realität unseres Lernprozesses, wenn wir daran zurückdenken, wann haben wir das jemals irgendwie gebraucht
oder wann hat uns das Nutzen gebracht, dass wir im Mathematikunterricht gewisse Dinge abstrakt gelernt haben?
Dann hat das erstaunlich wenig Gewicht und deshalb würde ich sagen, es gibt eigentlich kaum Ausnahmen, die nicht davon betroffen sind,
dass einfach Wiedergabe von bestimmten Wissen, dass das per sé eigentlich keinen Wert hat an der Schule,
sondern dass ich immer dieses Wissen einerseits in argumentative Strukturen einbinden muss und andererseits auch überlegen muss,
was fange ich damit an oder was hat das für mich für einen Sinn oder was hat das für die Welt für einen Sinn, wenn ich jetzt mich damit auseinandersetze.
Und das heißt nicht, dass man nichts wissen müsste, sondern dass ich, bevor ich etwas weiß, wissen muss, wozu schlage ich das jetzt nach?
Also weshalb, wofür kann ich diese Information verwenden, die ich jetzt gerade ermittle?
Und dann passiert was ganz anderes bei Lernprozessen, würde ich sagen, als das was das verbreitete Modell in der Schule ist.
Was wäre da jetzt ein Beispiel für, also wie man diese Umkehrung erfolgreich hinbekommt?
Ja so mein Idealbild für einen Grundschullehrer ist immer Wittgenstein, der mal seine Tätigkeit als Philosoph unterbrochen hat,
um in der Grundschule zu unterrichten und er ist eigentlich immer mit den Klassen rausgegangen, ist so ins Dorf und hat sich einfach mal angeschaut, was läuft da?
Und einer meiner Söhne ist jetzt in der ersten Klasse und die haben jetzt so Käfer.
Sie haben diese Käfer gesammelt und dann haben sie sich überlegt, ja was fressen die Käfer?
Das haben sie dann auch nachgeschlagen, dann haben sie denen das Futter gegeben.
Haben gelernt, die verpuppen sich, haben dann zugeschaut, wie machen die das?
Und haben wie durch die Interaktion mit dem, was um sie herum war, etwas herausgefunden, auch verstanden, das sind jetzt Lebewesen,
ich muss für die Sorgen, ich habe eine Verantwortung dafür und sie haben nicht einfach Blätter ausgemalt oder irgendwelche Informationen eingefüllt,
sondern das war auch wirklich da, was sie gemacht haben, das hatte für sie eine Bedeutung.
Und ich glaube, das kann man sehr stark verallgemeinern.
Ich finde ein Problem raus, das für mich eine Bedeutung hat oder ich begegne einem Problem und dann suche ich nach einer Lösung dafür.
Und ich kann jemandem erklären, was wir gemacht haben, warum wir es gemacht haben, wie wir es gemacht haben.
Und das glaube ich ist das, was zeitgemäßer Unterricht auch ist, dass man dann auch sagt, ich muss vielleicht Leute einbeziehen,
die davon eine Ahnung haben, ich muss Leute einladen, die davon etwas verstehen und davon wäre aus meiner Sicht viel viel mehr möglich.
Und da kann man auch den Bogen zur digitalen Bildung wieder schlagen, dass man sagt, ja der digitale Raum ist einer,
in dem die Schwellen für Begegnungen und für Fragen an Fachpersonen sehr niedrig geworden sind oder sehr niedrig sind
und da kann ich jetzt auch leicht jemandem eine Frage stellen oder mit jemandem in Kontakt treten, was sonst im klassischen Unterrichtssetting nicht möglich wäre.
Also Digitalisierung führt zu einer Öffnung der Schule oder einer möglichen Öffnung in verschiedene Richtungen.
Und das glaube ich könnte diese Art von Unterricht und von Wissenserwerb auch erleichtern oder vertiefen vielleicht, wenn wir es so sagen würden.
Und das funktioniert auch für alle Fächer?
Ja das behaupte ich jetzt einfach mal und ich weiß, dass es viele Leute gibt, die sagen würden, nein das funktioniert jetzt in diesem Fach nicht,
aber ich sehe jetzt prinzipiell keinen Einwand, warum das nicht in allen Fächern funktionieren sollte, wenn ich mir überlege,
was eigentlich der Sinn dieses …
also natürlich kann ich sagen, ja ich habe ein Fach, das braucht jetzt einfach niemand mehr.
Also wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ja man muss irgendwie stenografieren lernen oder in der Schule,
dann könnte ich sagen, ja es stenografiert jetzt einfach niemand mehr in der Welt, dann ist vielleicht schwierig zu begründen,
also wie könnte ich jetzt eine Anwendung schaffen für das Problem des Stenografierend, dann wird es schwierig.
Aber wenn das Fach einen Wert haben soll für die Kompetenzen, die junge Leute heute brauchen, dann müssen sich auch solche Probleme oder Anwendungen finden lassen,
die dann eben zu diesem Sinn kommen, der für mich ganz ganz wichtig ist.
Also es ist so, diese Nutzendiskussion, das ist doch etwas, wo Lehrkräfte sehr stark darin sind zu sagen, nein ihr sagt immer,
das, was wir in der Schule lernen, muss einen Nutze nahen, aber das ist so ein wirtschaftliches Argument, das stimmt gar nicht.
Und ich würde da mehr sagen, ja es muss einen Nutzen haben, aber es muss zunächst einen Nutzen für dich haben.
Wenn du etwas lernen musst, bei dem du nicht sagen kannst, was hat das für mich für eine Bedeutung, dann wird es sehr schwierig,
Motivation herzustellen, die Bereitschaft herzustellen, auch wirklich dran zu bleiben.
Und wenn das anders ist, dann öffnet das einfach viele Türen.
Ich würde jetzt ganz gerne nochmal auf so ein paar Begriffe zurückkommen, die ich ganz interessant fand, die in den Büchern,
also in den zusammengefassten Blogartikeln, zur Sprache kamen.
Und zwar der Nonsens und ich glaube der Untertitel ist so was wie, Schwimmenlernen im digitalen Chaos.
Wer nimmt denn dieses Chaos … also für mich persönlich ist ja Chaos ein sehr positiv besetztes Wort.
Andere Leute sehen das irgendwie anders, das ist ja immer so der Inbegriff des schlimmstmöglichen.
Chaos kann ja aber auch genauso gut bedeuten, man hat einfach eine unsortierte Wolke, in der eben keine Struktur vorgegeben ist.
Was macht der Begriff Nonsens hier in diesem Zusammenhang oder wie kann man das sortieren?
Ich habe jetzt schon direkt über diese Sinnfrage auch vorher schon gesprochen, dass etwas für mich als Lernender einen Sinn ergeben sollte
und Nonsens nimmt ja das gerade auf und sagt, das ist eigentlich eine Information, so verstehe ich das, die ich jemandem präsentiere,
ohne dass ich selbst sagen kann, das hat für mich einen Sinn oder es hat für die andere Person auch keinen.
Ich habe den Begriff auch deshalb gewählt, weil die ganze Debatte um Fakenews und dann gibt es ja philosophisch auch den Begriff des Bullshits,
es gibt verschiedene Kritik auch an diesem Fakenews Begriff, das war mir …
ja das ist vielleicht ein Marketingtrick, um zu sagen, ich habe einen eigenen Begriff, den ich jetzt etwas stark machen möchte,
aber andererseits wollte ich den so auch etwas als Überbegriff verwenden, weil ich so als These im Buch eigentlich präsentiert habe,
dass man zwar auf der politischen Ebene sehr schnell sagt, ja das ist jetzt ganz schlimm, da irgendwelche Internetkids aus Mazedonien,
die beeinflussen die US-Wahl und verschicken da irgendwelche Behauptungen, was Hillary Clinton alles gemacht haben soll.
Und da müssen wir doch irgendwie kritischer sein und gleichzeitig akzeptieren wir so in den Newsfeeds unserer SozialMedias solche Dinge zur Unterhalt, die klar erfunden sind.
Also die so dieses Hoax-Niveau haben oder so dieses, was früher eine Zeitungsente gewesen ist, das ist jetzt in unserem Alltag präsent.
So Geschichten, von denen wir gar nicht wissen können, stimmt das jetzt oder stimmt es nicht und häufig sind das auch so Marketingstunts,
dass wir erzählen, das ist dort und dort passiert und dann finden wir heraus, das war alles nur eine Inszenierung, das ist überhaupt nicht passiert und so weiter.
Und das wir eigentlich trainieren in einem Bereich mit Informationen umzugehen, die weder für uns noch für andere einen Sinn haben
und wir lernen, dass wir die irgendwie unterhaltsam finden könnten und gar nicht fragen dürfen, stimmt das jetzt oder stimmt das nicht?
Und dass man da natürlich auf einer politischen Ebene schlecht gerüstet ist, die Frage dann plötzlich zu stellen, stimmt das oder stimmt das nicht.
Und so wollte ich wie verschiedene Bereiche, bei denen ein ungutes Gefühl im Netz vorherrscht, wollte ich miteinander verbinden.
Und natürlich ist es so eine persönliche Marotte von mir auch, dass ich, wenn Leute so Dinge posten, bei denen eigentlich klar ist,
das stimmt wahrscheinlich gar nicht, das hat gar nie jemand so gesagt oder geschrieben, sondern ist nur erfunden,
dass ich dann das jeweils hinschreibe oder frage, weshalb findest du das jetzt lustig, wenn das gar niemand gesagt hat?
Aber viele Leute sehen den Punkt nicht ein und finden, bei Unterhaltung spielt das keine Rolle, wie jetzt der Status von dem ist, was wir da sehen.
Meine eng mit diesem digitalen Chaos oder ich sage mal so der Verwirrung, durch die sich manche, Junge wie Alte, durch die aktuelle digitale Realität ausgesetzt fühlen,
ist ja, dass auch so Aspekte wie Mobbing hier mit reinkommen.
Das heißt, man versucht irgendwie aktiv an dem Netz teilzunehmen, wird aber dann aus welchen Gründen auch immer so zu einer Opferperson,
alle schießen sich auf einen ein, man kann sich da überhaupt gar nicht mehr richtig ausleben und erzeugt dann auch entsprechende Ängste.
Ich meine, das ist nichts, was es nicht vorher gab, aber was zumindest in der aktuellen Wahrnehmung neue Dimensionen entwickelt,
weil es auch nicht so wahrnehmbar ist für andere, vielleicht auch nicht so nachvollziehbar, also findet das wirklich statt, warum ärgert dich das überhaupt?
Ist denn das eine Begleiterscheinung, die dann in der Schule auch mit reinkommt?
Also ist das ein Problem in der Schule?
Ja auf zwei Ebenen natürlich.
Einerseits der digitale Raum begleitet ja alles, was jetzt auch außerhalb des Digitalen passiert.
Und entsprechend, wenn in der Schule natürlich so was wie Mobbing-Strukturen auftauchen, dann hat das heute immer auch eine digitale Komponente
und viele Animositäten und Übergriffe finden auch in diesen digitalen Kommunikationsräumen statt, viele Verletzungen,
die in der Schule vielleicht gar nicht so besonders sichtbar sind für die Betroffenen – also für die Betroffenen schon – aber für den Lehrkörper vielleicht nicht.
Und das heißt, eigentlich so Mobbing-Situationen an Schulen werden verschärft dadurch, dass sie auch digital ausgetragen werden, das ist so die eine Ebene.
Und die andere Ebene ist, dass es eine gesellschaftliche Realität ist, dass es eine Möglichkeit für mich ist, mich im Netz auch auszudrücken
und dass ich irgendwie resilient sein müsste, wenn das jetzt passiert, wie gehe ich damit um, wie kann ich das ertragen, wie kann ich trotzdem weiter machen,
wenn ich mal auf so einer Welle des Hasses oder so etwas ausgesetzt bin, von Leuten, die ich jetzt gar nicht unbedingt kenne.
Und das sind beides natürlich … es hängt etwas miteinander zusammen, es ist einerseits die Aufgabe der Schule natürlich,
einen Raum zu schaffen, wo Leute Verantwortung für ihr Handeln übernehmen können und das heißt, Verantwortung bedeutet, sie werden auch infrage gestellt,
sie müssen antworten, sie müssen sich rechtfertigen und andererseits natürlich auch, es wird wahrgenommen, wenn sie etwas können,
wenn sie etwas gut machen, wenn sie sich auch für die, die mit ihnen lernen, einsetzen und sich um die sorgen.
Und wenn man das schafft in einer Klasse, so eine Gemeinschaft herzustellen, bei der alle Verantwortung übernehmen müssen,
dann wird das auch im digitalen Raum weniger Probleme geben.
Und andererseits merkt man dann, ich brauche halt ein Netzwerk.
Wann das sehr häufig passiert ist, ich äußere mich so in einem …
Ich adressiere ein Publikum, bei dem ich eigentlich nicht genau weiß, wer die Leute sind und erwarte dann bestimmte Reaktionen,
aber es kommen ganz andere Reaktionen zurück.
Das ist ja so eine Zutat, die für die diese Probleme denkbar sind.
Und die andere ist die, dass ich eigentlich Leute falsch einschätze, dass ich denke, ja ich kann denen das so mitteilen,
die verstehen was ich meine, aber die tun was völlig anderes damit, als ich eigentlich erwartet habe.
Die verletzen auch die Kontexte, die da vorgegeben sind und überschreiten die.
Und das gut einschätzen zu können, ich glaube da ist die Schule ein gutes Lernfeld, um zu sehen, wie fließen die Informationen,
wie kann ich kommunizieren, damit auch das ankommt, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, ohne dass ich jetzt die Schuld für solche Mobbing-Prozesse den Betroffenen geben möchte,
sondern einfach zu sagen, das ist ein Teil einer Strategie, um das zu vermeide, dass ich mir solche Dinge überlege und auch eine gewisse Stärke entwickle.
Aber letztlich ist es ein Problem, das zu unserer heutigen Welt gehört, wo ich nicht einen 100%-Schutz jemandem geben kann.
Es ist wie ein Autounfall, dass ich sagen kann, ich schaue mal, dass sich die Kinder irgendwie auf der Straße sicher bewegen können,
aber es wird immer wieder Unfälle geben und es ist denkbar, dass das natürlich auch im Internet der Fall ist.
Wo stehen wir denn jetzt quasi, wenn man jetzt mal drüber nachdenkt, wie das System auf solche Trends reagiert?
Ich meine in gewisser Hinsicht ist jetzt dein Unterricht auch wahrscheinlich etwas Avantgarde, da probiert mal jemand was aus,
der selber eine digitale Prägung hat, aber am Ende stellt sich ja immer die Frage, kriegt man das irgendwie systemisch hin?
Ist das nur eine Frage der Zeit und das passiert irgendwie von alleine oder sind wir irgendwie in so einer Verweigerungshaltung,
wo man sagt, wenn wir jetzt hier nicht mal für ein paar gute Beispiele oder Durchbrüche sorgt oder eben auch eine politische Wegbereitung macht,
dann passiert da irgendwie gar nichts?
Ja auf jeden Fall ist es ein System, das sich bewegen muss und wo natürlich auch die Anreize des Systems so gegeben sein müssen,
dass auch das eintritt, was man sich wünscht.
Also wenn man sagt, ja man möchte, dass so etwas skaliert, wie ich jetzt den Unterricht mache, dass das auch Verbreitung findet,
dann müssen dazu auch Anreize vorhanden sein an den Schulen selbst oder in der Bildungspolitik.
Und ich kann es vielleicht an einem Punkt klar machen, ich habe mal auf einer Veranstaltung gesagt, ich würde, wenn ich in der Schulleitung wäre,
würde ich nur Leute einstellen, die ein digitales Portfolio haben.
Und ich habe selten so heftigen Gegenwind bekommen, wie für diese Behauptung, weil natürlich viele gestandene Lehrkräfte gemerkt haben,
da könnte ich gar nicht mithalten, ich habe kein Portfolio, ich weiß nicht wozu.
Also Portfolio jetzt nicht im Sinne von, ich habe eine Homepage, wo draufsteht, wie ich heiße, sondern man kann irgendwas vorweisen,
was man im Netz gemacht hat oder?
Also zunächst mal, ja ich habe natürlich erklärt, was ich mit Portfolio meine, aber zunächst einmal einfach, ich finde die Person auch im Netz.
also ich suche danach und dann finde ich raus, was macht die, wofür begeistert die sich, was sind ihre Projekte.
Und dass ich das mal erwarten würde und dann natürlich in einem weiteren Schritt, dass die Person auch gewisse Dinge, was sie im Unterricht macht, auch im Netz dokumentiert,
damit man irgendwelche Anschlüsse dazu herstellen kann.
Das ist natürlich jetzt schon sehr idealistisch, aber zunächst einmal einfach sagen, so eine persönliche Homepage, das wäre mal eine gute Ausgangslage oder Basis für so ein Portfolio.
Und dass ich bei Leuten, die das nicht haben, nicht irgendwie denken würde, ach ja das ist jetzt professionell, sondern fragen würde, weshalb haben Sie das nicht?
Was ist denn, weshalb präsentieren Sie Ihre Arbeiten oder Ihre Fähigkeiten nicht im Netz, das ist doch irgendwie seltsam?
Aber so ist es heute nicht, sondern man findet es eher seltsam, wenn Leute sich im Netz präsentieren.
Und dass man das kippen müsste, das war so eine Aussage dazu.
Und weiter wäre natürlich, dass man die Leute …
also ich würde jetzt sagen, ich bin in gewissen Bereichen ein Pionier und ich bin nicht alleine, es gibt viele andere,
aber die Leute reiben sich fast mir auf, weil sie immer wieder zu einem Punkt kommen, wo sie jemanden überzeugen müssen
oder wo ihnen vorgeworfen wird, dass das alles nur sehr oberflächlich ist, dass das gar nichts bringt.
Und dass es, um ein Pionier zu sein, weniger Anstrengung braucht oder weniger Widerstandskraft, dass es im System einfacher wird für diese Leute.
Das wäre so ein Schritt, wo man gewisse Dinge tun könnte, also neben der Anstellung wäre es natürlich auch, wie geht man denn damit um?
Wie macht man das sichtbar?
Und daneben gibt es natürlich viele andere Punkte, die immer wieder einen Rückfall darstellen.
Ich habe schon so diese Modelle des Frontalunterrichts oder des Erklärens, wir bauen jetzt mal Wissen auf, die auch auf diesen Edu-Kanälen bei YouTube sehr verbreitet sind,
habe ich schon erwähnt und der Punkt, der die ja immer befördert oder der Anreiz schafft, um so zu lernen oder so Wissen zu vermitteln,
ist ja eigentlich die Prüfungskultur, dass man sagen muss, ja bei der Prüfung musst du das aber genauso können oder genauso hinschreiben.
Und wenn diese Prüfungen geändert würden, wenn man da etwas machen könnte, das wäre für mich der zentrale Punkt,
dann würde man bei vielen Formen des Unterrichts sagen, ja das bringt mir jetzt dazu ja gar nichts.
Und dazu glaube ich müsste die Bildung mal ein bisschen schauen, wie werden denn heute in Unternehmen Leute eingestellt, nach welchen Kriterien werden sie ausgewählt
und dann merkt man, dass diese Prüfungen und Abschlüsse sehr an Bedeutung verloren haben, aber im Schulsystem haben sie immer noch die absolut zentrale Bedeutung.
Und viele Leute können ihre fragwürdige Didaktik dadurch rechtfertigen, dass sie sagen, das ist halt die ideale Prüfungsvorbereitung,
und das stimmt halt tatsächlich teilweise noch, dass die Prüfungen wirklich so funktionieren.
Und da sind die Prüfungstraditionen und die bildungspolitischen Vorstellungen, was eine Prüfung leistet, halt sehr sehr weit von der didaktischen Forschung des Lernens entfernt.
Also man meint, man könne gewisse Fähigkeiten abprüfen, obwohl das gar nicht möglich ist auf diese Art und Weise.
Oder man denkt, das sei eine gute Prüfung, obwohl es gar keine gute Prüfung ist.
Und das ist ein Kampf, der schon seit Jahrzehnten eigentlich ausgetragen wird, das haben immer wieder Leute gesagt,
aber trotzdem scheint es aus gewissen Grüdnen nicht möglich zu sein, diese Prüfungskultur irgendwie auch ein Stück voran zu bringen.
Weil die Widerstände zu groß sind?
Ja.
Oder weil keinem was besseres einfällt?
Weil halt sehr viel auch davon abhängt, genau und weil die Vorstellungen so das Bauchgefühl sehr verbreitet ist, dass Schule genau so funktionieren sollte
oder weil natürlich ein ganz starkes Problem ist, dass die Leute, die über Schule entscheiden, dass die selber auch schon eine Schule durchlaufen haben.
Wenn man sagt, man muss das jetzt zu stark verändern oder man muss da was anders machen, dann ist es immer auch eine Entwertung der eigenen Schulbildung,
dass man denkt, ja ich bin ja so erfolgreich, dass ich jetzt über Dinge entscheiden kann, weil ich gerade diese Schule durchlaufen habe.
Das ist zwar ein enorm starker Bios, der so mit dem eigenen Erfolg auch zu tun hat, dass man denkt, ja deshalb ist es ja eine gute Schule,
weil ich habe es ja zu etwas gebracht mit dieser Schule.
Und das ist schwierig, dann daran zu rütteln, würde ich jetzt sagen oder es geht immer  nur in sehr kleinen Schritten voran.
Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt so im Netz bewegt und man hat immer so ein bisschen den Vorteil, dass man von vornherein schon mal ein bisschen überregionaler orientiert ist,
vielleicht eben auch internationaler, was nimmst du denn so an internationalen Bewegungen wahr in anderen Ländern, gut Beispiele jetzt außerhalb der Schweiz,
die es vielleicht mal wert wären, ausprobiert zu werden, oder die vielleicht auch schon an anderen Stellen bewiesen haben, dass sie den richtigen oder eine guten Umgang mit Digitalisierung darstellen?
Gibt es da was?
Ja, also so das beeindruckendste Modell sind so die Schulen, die auch von Hattie beeinflusst sind, so vor allem in Neuseeland gibt es teilweise …
Die wovon beeinflusst sind?
Ach so Hattie, das ist so dieser Bildungsforscher.
Und die Schulen gehen von Anfang an davon aus, dass Schülerinnen und Schüler verstehen müssen, was lernen ist.
Also sie lernen zuerst nicht die Buchstaben oder das Einmaleins oder sowas, sondern sie lernen, wie lerne ich eigentlich?
Also was bedeutet es, etwas zu lernen?
Und dann gehen sie immer mit dieser Perspektive an gewisse Fragestellungen ran, was muss ich tun, um das wirklich zu verstehen?
Um es auch behalten zu können und Kompetenzen aufzubauen.
Und das dokumentieren sie sehr oft auch digital in so Lernjournalen und sie arbeiten in diesen Schulen auch so in Lernecken
und das ist auch etwas, was in der skandinavischen Bildungslandschaft, also Finnland, Schweden, auch Dänemark teilweise,
da gibt es sehr innovative Projekte, die auch so eine gewisse Selbstverständlichkeit der digitalen Kommunikation voraussetzen.
Dass man Fächergrenzen beispielsweise überwinden kann, dass man sehr interdisziplinär arbeitet, dass man auch neue Räume braucht, um lernen zu können,
also da sieht man, dass digitale Bildung natürlich viel viel mehr meint, als einfach Geräte einzuschalten oder Geräte in den Unterricht mitzubringen.
Ja das wären so die Beispiele, die mir am direktesten in den Sinn kommen.
Ich würde auch sagen, dass gewisse Colleges in den USA schon sehr viel weiter sind was das anbetrifft.
Das gibt es natürlich in der angelsächsischen Tradition – da ist es ja schon immer so, dass man sich ja für die guten Universitäten der USA bewerben muss
und dass man dort auch schon so diesen Portfoliogedanken etwas vertritt, dass man eigentlich eine Uni überzeugen muss, dass man auch für diese Kultur etwas beitragen könnte.
Und da reicht es nicht, einfach Noten zu haben oder Abschlüsse, sondern man muss auch dokumentieren, was man außerhalb der Schule gemacht hat,
welche Porjekte man gestemmt hat und dieses Projektdenken, das glaube ich schon, dass man das auch viel tiefer verankern könnte oder sollte,
um auch heraus zu finden, wer wirklich zu einer Kultur dann auch passt.
Ja, das wären so die Punkte, die ich so direkt sagen könnte.
Also das sind ja mehr so organisatorische Fragen.
Sozusagen mehr: „Wie organisiere ich den Unterricht an sich?“
Jetzt mal ganz unabhängig von der Digitalisierung, oder trägt das nur dazu bei?
Also wenn ich jetzt sage, ich hab jetzt nicht mehr Deutsch im Fach, sondern das ist so ein Aspekt, der in mehreren Projektgruppen auch eine Rolle spielt
und dann muss ich mir halt, so versteh ich das jetzt mal, für den jeweiligen Fall die entsprechende Fähigkeit auch erarbeiten?
Ist es das, was du meinst?
Ja, genau.
Dass es darauf hinauf laufen soll?
Und da gibt es natürlich auch – also …
Ich finde auch, dass es in Deutschland sehr sehr gute Beispiele gibt bei innovativen Schulen, teilweise auch bei Privatschulen,
die Modelle professionalisiert haben, die aus der Reformpädagogik kommen, die durchaus auch sehr aufgeschlossen sind, was den Einbezug von digitalen Geräten betrifft.
Aber ich formuliere das jetzt mehr so als eine Systemperspektive oder als eine Öffnungsperspektive, weil die Gefahr ist so die,
die es in den USA gibt, bei Schulen, die eigentlich so aussehen wie so diese amerikanischen Büros, wo alle in so einem Cubicle sitzen vor einem Bildschirm.
Und die haben einfach so eine Lernmanagement-Software und klicken sich durch irgendwelche Lernumgebungen durch.
Und das ist dann so eine Lernfabrik, wo ich denke, das darf auf keinen Fall passieren.
Und das ist so das, wo natürlich die großen Konzerne in der Bildungsindustrie, wo sie denken
„Ja, Bildung ist ein Markt.“
Und da investieren die Staaten viel, da investieren Private auch viel und wenn wir mit unseren Produkten so reinkommen,
dass halt ein Kind nur noch ein Tablet braucht und dann darauf all die Dinge tun kann, die sie heute in der Schule machen,
dann sehe ich das als sehr sehr gefährlich an.
Und deshalb muss sich auch im Schulsystem unbedingt etwas bewegen,
weil das sonst etwas ist, was Google und Facebook und Amazon uns sagen werden, wie Bildung funktioniert in der Zukunft.
Und da glaube ich nicht, dass wir da hin wollen und dass das eine gute Art ist, um das zu vermitteln, was an der Schule vermittelt werden sollte,
oder das für die Gesellschaft zu leisten.
Das heißt man könnte sogar sagen, die Schulen stehen eigentlich jetzt auch unter dem Druck, eigene Antworten liefern zu müssen
bevor die Antworten, wie Schule funktioniert, oder wie Bildung funktioniert, von außerhalb vorgeschrieben wird?
hm (bejahend) Man kann ja sagen, also diese Disruption, die in bestimmten Bereichen – für mich ist es immer der Journalismus,
der mich auch deshalb fasziniert hat, weil ich denke, da wurde ja recht schnell deutlich:
So wie ihr es bis hierher gemacht habt, das wird einfach schon wirtschaftlich nicht mehr aufgehen.
Ihr müsst neue Wirtschaftsmodelle suchen, ihr müsst aber auch neue Formate finden,
das Netz kommt zuerst und dann könnt ihr was ausdrucken, wenn ihr wollt
Da mussten viele Leute sich viele Fragen stellen und das ging sehr sehr schnell.
Und in der Schule geht alles sehr sehr langsam, weil man ahnt zwar, da könnte sich was bewegen, aber man macht einfach so weiter, wie bisher.
Und das hat auch noch niemandem geschadet, einfach so weiter machen, wie bisher.
Das ging bisher gut.
Und wenn man sich jetzt fragt: „Ja, was wird passieren?“, dann kann man sagen, da wo man es schon merkt ist,
dass es in gewissen Fächern Schülerinnen und Schüler gibt, die sagen:
„Ahja gut, erzählen Sie mal, aber ich schau mir das zu Hause dann hinterher ohnehin nochmal auf YouTube an.
Und dort erklärt es jemand wirklich gut.“
Dass man sagen kann, ja einfach so erklären, wie das auch jemand auf YouTube könnte, das ist sicher etwas, was in Zukunft nicht mehr trägt.
Das macht niemand mehr mit.
Und da, glaube ich, sind Unis schon viel weiter, dass sie merken, Vorlesungen, das ist kein Format mehr, was Zukunft hat.
Weil: Vorlesungen werden im Netz abgehalten, da braucht es niemanden mehr, der in einen Hörsaal geht.
Das kostet auch zu viel, usw.
Und dann könnte man sich ja weiter überlegen, was wird dann der nächste Schritt von dieser Disruption sein?
Und das wird sein, dass gewisse Dinge – wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Vokabular für eine Sprache aufbauen will, dann gibt es ja schon Lernsoftware,
wo ich jetzt so die gebräuchlichen Fremdsprachen, also so Französisch, Englisch, Spanisch, sowas, kann ich ja sehr sehr gut auch mit einer App lernen.
Auch auf der Ausspracheebene – ich kann es vorsagen, die App hört mit, die ist interaktiv.
Also, kann ich mir überlegen, wie muss an der Schule passieren, damit da noch ein Mehrwert vorhanden ist vielleicht, oder damit die Schule was leisten kann, was so digitale Apps nicht können.
Und das ist eine Frage – bei Weiterbildungen und Vorträgen sage ich das sehr häufig:
Ihr müsst euch einfach als Schule überlegen:
„Was ist denn das, was ihr besser könnt als irgendeine App es kann?“
Und das glaube ich wäre dann so wie die zweite Welle der Disruption, die vielleicht eintreten wird, oder vielleicht dauert das auch noch eine Weile.
Wo man einfach den Leuten nicht mehr vernünftig erklären kann, weshalb soll jetzt ein Kind in die Schule gehen,
wenn es doch zu Hause diese App hätte, mit der es dasselbe viel schneller und viel einfacher lernen könnte.
Und wenn Schulen natürlich dazu übergehen, Digitalisierung einfach so zu verstehen:
„Ich installiere mal auf den Tablets einfach mal die richtige App, damit die Kinder das dann lernen.“
Dann schaffen sie sich eigentlich selbst ab, kann man sagen.
Sie müssen sich überlegen, wie sie das tun können, ohne sich selbst abzuschaffen.
Meine Antwort darauf wäre, dass es immer noch ein soziales Miteinander ist, also die Begegnungen, die an der Schule möglich werden,
dass ich merke, es ist eigentlich auch die ganze Breite der Gesellschaft vorhanden.
Da gibt es Leute, die aus einem anderen Bereich stammen, die auch andere Kompetenzen haben, oder andere Perspektiven auf die Welt,
dass man die Verbindung dieser Perspektiven stark macht, dass man echte Kollaboration auch stark macht und sagt:
„Es braucht Leute, die das aus verschiedenen Blickwinkeln angehen.“
Das scheint mir sehr sehr wichtig zu sein und ich glaube da hat die Schule, gerade im deutschsprachigen Raum, sehr großes Potential,
weil man ja so sagen kann, bei vielen unreflektierten Leuten sagt man ja:
„Das ist eine gute Schule, in dieser Klasse sprechen 18 Kinder Deutsch als Muttersprache.
Das ist eine schlechte Schule, neben meinem Kind sprechen nur noch zwei andere Deutsch als Muttersprache.“
Dass das als ein Qualitätskriterium angesehen wird, dass Kinder eine andere Sprache sprechen, ist ja komplett absurd,
weil eigentlich wäre das ja eine Ressource, dass man sagt, in dieser Klasse gibt es 20 Kinder, die auch noch eine andere Sprache sprechen.
Die sprechen ja schon auch Deutsch, aber zu Hause kennen sie eine andere Kultur, eine andere Sprache.
Aber das ist im heutigen System eine Belastung, weil das System zu homogen ist.
Man kann nicht sagen, ja jetzt können noch fünf Kinder in dieser Klasse Portugiesisch oder Türkisch,
das ist ja toll, weil wir jetzt endlich ein Projekt machen können, wo wir das auch irgendwie mit einbinden, dass die das können,
sondern: Nein, das ist ein Problem, weil ihr eigentlich nur Deutsch sprechen müsst an der Schule.
Also diese Vorstellung wird sich sehr stark gemacht.
Und Diversität und Zusammenarbeit, so wie echt umzusetzen, ich glaube da könnte die Schule einen Schritt vorwärts machen und das können Apps halt wirklich nicht,
also diesen menschlichen Faktor auch mit einbinden.
In der 22. Ausgabe von Forschergeist hatte ich mich mit Jürgen Handke aus Marburg unterhalten, der im Prinzip genau das zelebriert, was du ja auch erwähnt hast,
an der Universität, also quasi diese Flip-Class-Show?? so um die Umkehrung, um das repetitive Element aus der Universität raushält
und quasi die Universität sich, zumindest in seiner Fakultät, mehr so als ein Dienstleister versteht, der eben dieses vorgekaute Basiswissen zur Anwendung bringt,
konkret in Projekte eingliedert und dann eben die eigentliche Dienstleistung mehr so eine Art Lernsupport ist, so:
Jetzt unterstütze ich dich dabei, das was du quasi dir einmal so grob reingezogen hast, das eben auch wirklich zur Anwendung zu bringen.
Ist das übertragbar auf ein Gymnasium, ist das auch übertragbar auf eine Grundschule, oder ist das auch eine Fähigkeit, die man erst älteren Schülern zumuten sollte?
Nein, also ich glaube, man sollte sie allen zumuten, aber natürlich stufengerecht.
Also, was heißt jetzt, ein Projekt durchzuführen oder zusammen zu arbeiten in der Grundschule?
Was heißt es auf dem Gymnasium?
Da sind ganz ganz andere Möglichkeiten und das ist schon die Aufgabe der Didaktik, es so hinzukriegen, dass es auf dieser Stufe tatsächlich umsetzbar ist.
Was ist dann auch möglich, es irgendwie selbstständig zu erarbeiten, selbst orientiert, wozu braucht es dann vielleicht auch eine Ansprechperson, eine Person, die einen motivieren kann?
Ich glaube, das kann man nicht verallgemeinern und sagen, das ist auf jeder Stufe genau gleich.
Aber das Argument, jüngere und schwächere Lernende könnten nicht auf diese Art und Weise lernen, halte ich für sehr sehr falsch.
Ich glaube, dass das auch ein großes Defizit der deutschsprachigen Bildungslandschaft ist, dass man sagt, ja diese innovativen Lernformen gehen schon, aber nur bei den Talentierten oder bei den Fortgeschrittenen.
Ich glaube, Lernenden zu zeigen, Verantwortung für ihr Lernen zu übernehmen und sich auch zu überlegen:
„Was möchte ich wissen, oder wie könnte ich einen Schritt vorankommen?“
Das geht schon bei sehr sehr jungen Schülerinnen und Schülern.
Da ist die fatale Auswirkung an dieser Vorstellung ist, dass Schulsozialisation sehr stark von einem überholten Modell ausgeht, dass man sagt, ja alle –
also man spricht dann so von verschiedenen Gs, ich glaube so 7 G, 9 G, 11 G, ich weiß es nicht, ob ich es hinkriege,
alle machen zur gleichen Zeit, im gleichen Tempo, mit der gleichen Methode, lernen sie die gleichen Inhalte mit der gleichen Motivation zum gleichen Zweck usw.
Dass man davon weg kommen könnte und auch weg kommen müsste ist eigentlich naheliegend, wird aber dadurch verhindert, dass man sagt,
zuerst muss man zu diesen Gs kommen und alle müssen lernen, ich muss irgendwie auf meinem Platz sitzen, ich muss ruhig sein, es kann immer nur eine Person sprechen, man muss aufzeigen, usw.
Das braucht ja sehr viel Energie, bis das alle Kinder mal verstanden haben, wie das funktioniert.
Und das hat ja den Sinn, dass gerade dieser Gleichschritt dadurch auch eingeführt wird, aber wenn man sich eine heutige erste Klasse ansieht,
dann ist die schon so heterogen, dass man sich fragen kann, weshalb man all diese Energie überhaupt aufwendet, um alle an den gleichen Punkt zu kriegen.
Wenn man, z.B. jetzt bei meinem Sohn, ich glaube man geht in der Schweiz auch ein Jahr später in die erste Klasse als in Deutschland,
aber da gibt es Kinder, die haben schon 20 Bücher gelesen, wenn sie in die erste Klasse kommen.
Und die lesen einfach alle zwei Tage ein Buch.
Und andere können nicht einmal ihren Namen schreiben, die können nicht die Buchstaben lesen, die zu ihrem Namen dazu gehören.
Und da jetzt zu sagen, wir bringen jetzt alle mal an einen Punkt, wo wir gemeinsam Unterricht machen müssen usw., das ist, glaube ich, sehr problematisch,
aber es hat einen starken Effekt, dass alle denken, so muss Schule sein:
Also wenn da vorne jemand steht, und wir alle gemeinsam das selbe abhandeln, dann ist das richtige Schule, und alles andere ist irgendwie ein bisschen seltsam,
oder da kann ich nicht so gut lernen, oder so funktioniert das nicht …
Da muss man schon sehen, dass das auch sehr stark abgespeichert und mit eigenen Vorstellungen verbunden wird, wie Schule funktioniert, oder was Lernen ist.
Und das halte ich für etwas gefährlich.
Ist das nicht quasi auch dadurch, dass alles so auf die Idee eines frontalen und vor allem nur eines Lehrers pro Klasse hin optimiert ist?
Und müsste man nicht mit der Logik dann auch darüber nachdenken, Klassen und die entsprechende Betreuung auch personell anders aufzustellen?
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt insgesamt mehr Lehrer, das vielleicht auch, aber dass sich überhaupt mehrere Lehrer gleichzeitig um eine Klasse kümmern?
Weil wenn es sehr unterschiedliche Dinge gibt, die mehr oder wenig gleichzeitig gefördert werden müssen, hier/da wird was anderes gelernt, weil das schon gekonnt wird, als im anderen Teil der Klasse, dass man da auch mit mehreren Leuten arbeitet?
Ist das überhaupt realistisch?
Auf jeden Fall, ja, also ich finde jetzt die Schule, auf der meine Kinder sind, die arbeitet in diesem Punkt schon recht gut und hat natürlich auch die nötigen Ressourcen:
Da sind teilweise drei oder vier Personen für eine Klasse zuständig, auch teilweise gleichzeitig im Schulzimmer, aber das kostet natürlich auch sehr sehr viel, um das finanzieren zu können.
Das ist sicher ein Modell, das ganz wichtig wäre.
Das hat sicher auch mit der Rolle der Lehrperson zu tun.
Es hängt dann natürlich auch noch ein bisschen – es gibt noch andere Fragen bei der diese Rollen natürlich geändert werden müssen.
Also bspw. gestern hat mir eine Kollegin erzählt, ihr Sohn ist auf dem Gymnasium und will ein Hörspiel oder einen Podcast aufnehmen.
Dann hat er sich irgendwie in Audacity eingearbeitet und jetzt hat er eine Geräuschbibliothek im Netz gefunden, die er gern nutzen würde, er braucht aber etwas Hilfe dabei, die irgendwie einzufügen.
Und dann hat der Lehrer gesagt:
„Nein, ich habe hier noch ein Tonbandgerät und ein Mikrofon, mach es einfach damit, weil das kann ich auch, da kann ich dir helfen, aber beim anderen kann ich dir nicht helfen.“
Und da ein Verständnis zu haben, dass ich als Lehrer oft mit Klassen auch Dinge mache, die ich vielleicht nicht verstehe, also dass ich
z.B. jetzt ich als Deutschlehrer jetzt mal die Bereitschaft habe, mal eine Stunde über ein Buch zu sprechen, das ich nicht gelesen habe,
wo ich nicht sagen kann, ich weiß am Meisten über das Buch, sondern ich kann nur das Gespräch moderieren.
Ich kann zeigen, wie man über das sprechen kann, aber ich selber bin nicht der, der am Meisten über dieses Thema weiß hier in diesem Raum.
Und das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig, schon auf der Grundschule zu sagen, ich muss als Lehrperson oder als Lehrkraft nicht thematisch überlegen sein,
sondern ich muss den Lernprozess gestalten und ich kann auch zulassen, dass das Lernen auf ein Terrain gerät, wo ich selber nicht wirklich den Überblick habe,
sondern ich finde dann irgendwie wieder zurück, oder ich kann die mal machen lassen und wir nehmen das dann einander? Erst mal auf.
Das ist auch in der Zusammenarbeit häufig, dass man dann sagt, wenn wir jetzt zu zweit sind, dann kann das leicht irgendwo hin gehen, wo ich dann nicht mehr so sicher bin, und ich will es kontrollieren können.
Da kann man sagen, das ist natürlich auch eine Auswirkung der Digitalisierung.
Die Metapher vom Kontrollverlust ist ja sehr verbreitet und das gilt natürlich auch für die Schule, dass man häufig die Kontrolle verliert über das, was man gerne kontrollieren möchte
und dass das eigentlich auch was Gutes ist.
Also da würde ich jetzt dir auch beipflichten mit dem Chaosbegriff, wenn dann so ein Chaos entsteht, dass man sagt, es ist nicht mehr jemand, der jetzt das alles kontrolliert,
sondern es kann auch etwas dynamisches passieren.
Das scheint mir wichtig zu sein.
Nur, um wieder zurück zu kommen auf die Frage, das würde ja dann heißen, dass die Schulen entsprechend auch geschulte Leute bekommen, die auch mit diesem Rollenbild irgendwie leben können,
und es sind auch Leute, die gut zusammenarbeiten können, die natürlich auch so bezahlt werden, dass es sich für sie lohnt auch zu zweit, zu dritt, in einem Klassenzimmer zu stehen
oder neue Lernformen auch anzubieten und da sind ja die Mittel jetzt auch nicht gerade so üppig vorhanden und das führt zu der Verknüpfung, dass man Digitalisierung häufig auch als ein Sparprojekt denkt.
Und zwar, es so ganz laut auszusprechen, wagt das eigentlich niemand, aber so von der Seite dieser Konzerne, die ich schon angesprochen habe, glaube ich schon, dass das ein Gedanke ist.
Dass man sagt, ja ein Schulträger kann sparen, der kann auch Personalkosten einsparen, wenn die Kinder digital lernen.
Und das ist natürlich dann von meinem Verständnis von Bildung und von Schule her sehr sehr problematisch, wenn man sagt, ja das, was Menschen tun, das wird jetzt einfach durch Geräte ersetzt.
Funktioniert doch gar nicht, oder?
Nein, das kann gar nicht funktionieren.
Aber die Geräte können helfen?
Ja, die Geräte können bei den Dingen helfen, die repetitiv sind, die auch Übungen darstellen.
Man spricht so von einer Unterrichtsqualität, d.h. intelligentes Üben und das können die Geräte.
Also ich glaube, die können intelligente Übungen durchführen und die können mir helfen, vielleicht auch so ein bisschen meinen inneren Schweinehund zu überwinden.
Also ich gehe ab und zu joggen mit so einer Jogging-App, und die kann schon helfen zu sagen, jetzt schau mal an was hast du das letzte Mal gemacht, was machst du heute?
Jetzt müsste es doch ein bisschen schneller gehen, jetzt überwinde dich mal.
Also mir mal deutlich zu machen, wo ich stehe, und mir auch die Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen um meinen Lernprozess reflektieren zu können,
weil wir uns ja auch ständig irgendwelche Dinge über uns auch selbst auch einbilden.
Und zu sagen, ja ich muss jetzt halt wirklich die Französisch-Wörter lernen und ich muss versuchen, es besser zu können als beim letzten Mal, dazu kann eine App natürlich sehr sehr hilfreich sein.
So der digitale Arschtritt, um überhaupt erst mal wieder in Wallungen zu kommen.
Und dann können diese Daten natürlich auch für Lehrkräfte aufschlussreich sein, wenn man sagt, ja ich habe jetzt bemerkt, also die Schülerinnen und Schüler können das alles schon,
oder die brauchen noch ein bisschen Hilfe, die haben das nicht gemacht, da kann ich noch Unterstützung anbieten.
Ich glaube schon, dass man da auch an der Unterrichtsqualität schrauben könnten, wenn man teilweise solche Daten hätte.
Aber das ist natürlich kein Allheilmittel, sondern es muss immer sehr gut kontextualisiert werden und es muss auch abgesprochen werden, wie das tatsächlich auch eingesetzt wird.
Es ist wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so einfach, sich von diesem Gedanken zu trennen, dass man, wie heute, so einen Lernplan hat, in dem klar gegeben ist, welche Lernziele man hat
und dann natürlich auch sehr viel Material und ich weiß nicht, wie ausführlich das dann letztlich niedergeschrieben ist, zu erläutern, so hat das jetzt auch dargebracht zu werden.
Mit dem pädagogischen Rüstzeug, was man eben so gelernt hat, ist man ja in der Lage, die Klasse irgendwie zu managen, dass sie einem nicht aufs Dach steigt,
hin zu einem eigentlich auch anderen Selbstverständnis zu kommen, dass man sagt, OK, wir haben jetzt sehr mehr – ihr habt sehr viel mehr Möglichkeiten, ihr habt sehr viel mehr Infrastruktur,
Lernen teilweise einfach selber zu organisieren, was dann eben auch effizient sein kann, vielleicht auch – ich will es ja gar nicht mehr so sehr mit diesem
„Das ist dann billiger, wenn ihr das so macht.“
Sondern, ihr habt dann sozusagen die Bibliothek, wo man sonst einmal die Woche hingeht, um sich was auszuleihen, die ist ja immer da.
So, und wenn man das eben lernt und wenn man sich auch selber als Lehrer anders versteht, und sagt OK, ich bin jetzt eigentlich mehr euer Lernbegleiter, so der Bildungs-Sputnik,
und ich trete auch einen Schritt zurück und sage OK, meine Rolle ist auch gar nicht primär, die Wissensquelle zu sein, sondern eigentlich mehr so der Bildungsflugeinweiser, zu sagen:
„Okay, wenn du jetzt nicht weißt, wo du jetzt weiter machen sollst, probier es doch mal da.“
Schülern letztlich vielleicht auch mehr das Gefühl zu geben, dass sie das selber herausfinden müssen, auch wichtiger ist.
Ja, und ich glaube das ist auch etwas, was ich so als eine meiner – ich find das Wort „Vorbild“ etwas schwierig, aber vielleicht wie die Vorbildwirkung von dem, was ich im Netz mache
wie auch für die, die es interessiert, auch deutlich zu machen:
Ich selbst lerne auch dazu, ich habe Projekte, ich möchte Dinge herausfinden, ich verstehe jetzt Dinge noch nicht und ich muss mich da einarbeiten.
Und das glaube ich, das ist ganz entscheidend, dass man sich so auch als Lehrerin oder Lehrer auch präsentiert und sagt:
Ich selber arbeite auch noch an meinem eigenen Lernen, und dass das auch eine Strahlkraft hat.
Und wenn man sich präsentiert:
Also ich hab alles schon verstanden und ich hab abgeschlossen mit Lernen, und ich argumentiere jetzt aus dieser fertigen Position heraus,
das funktioniert sehr schlecht, glaube ich, und das ist ein schlechtes Rollenverständnis.
Also müssen sich die neuen Lehrer so ein bisschen anders aufstellen in der Hinsicht?
Es wäre schön, wenn sie das täten, ja.
Das braucht natürlich auch eine gewisse Muße, man braucht Zeit dafür, man muss auch Anerkennung dafür bekommen, es muss auch irgendwie wahrgenommen werden
und nicht als eine Schwäche ausgelegt werden, wenn man sagt:
Ja das kann ich noch nicht, oder da habe ich einen Fehler gemacht.
Also, vieles ist natürlich ein Schlagwort, dass man von Fehlerkultur spricht, aber den Mut zu haben, im Netz auch mal einen Fehler einzugestehen, oder auch wirklich öffentlich zu denken,
dass man sehen kann, da wird auch Falsches gesagt oder man muss mal einen Schritt zurück gehen.
Ich glaube, das ist eigentlich sehr wohltuend, aber da fehlt vielen Leuten, die im pädagogischen Bereich arbeiten, schlicht die Bereitschaft, das auch zu machen.
Und das ist eines der Hindernisse, weshalb sich diese ganze Netzkultur eigentlich an der Schule gar nicht wirklich durchgesetzt hat und es eigentlich immer nur Ausnahmen sind,
die da wirklich mitmachen oder auch bereit sind, da wirklich weit zu gehen.
Und was sagt der Optimismus, wird das stattfinden?
Ja, der Optimismus sagt, ich habe kürzlich mal auf einem Blog einen Kommentar hinterlassen, wo die Frage war:
Wie kann man denn die Leute, die eigentlich gar nicht verstehen wollen, was im Netz abläuft, wie kann man die überzeugen?
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja irgendwann werden sie einfach merken, dass ihre Haltung gar nicht mehr gut ankommt, dass es nicht mehr so cool ist,
dass man eigentlich damit keine Punkte mehr sammeln kann.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Germanistik, da haben die coolen Intellektuellen lange Zeit, also als ich studiert habe, hat man so Kopien bekommen,
die haben einfach so ausgesehen, als ob man bewusst versucht hätte, noch irgendwelche Dinge auszuschneiden und das schwarz zu machen.
Also es hat einfach nie professionell und sauber gemacht gewirkt.
Und das war immer so cool: „Ich bin halt irgendwie zu vergeistigt um zu verstehen, wie ein Kopierer funktioniert, und deshalb gebe ich euch jetzt das so ab.“
Und so ist es ja mit dem Netz immer noch, dass gewisse Leute denken:
„Ich bin zu stark in meinem Denken verstrickt als dass ich mich jetzt irgendwie mit Technologie abgeben könnte.“
Irgendwann, glaube ich, wird sich das ändern, dass man sagen kann:
Ja, du bildest dir das vielleicht noch ein, dass das irgendwie professionell ist, was du machst, aber es ist es nicht mehr.
Also dass man nicht mehr denken kann, irgendjemand nimmt einem das ab, sondern man wirkt dann einfach so als würde man noch im letzten Jahrhundert leben.
Und das ist so die Hoffnung, dass sich dann so ein bisschen wie automatisch die Reputation vielleicht ein bisschen verändert in dieser Richtung.
Und dass man nicht mehr mit dem Analogen kokettieren kann, weil das beobachtet man ja, so dieses:
Ja, ich mach das ja hier noch so ganz traditionell etc. und irgendwann …
Man schämt sich sozusagen noch nicht ausreichend dafür.
So könnte man es sagen, ja.
Und ich würde sagen ich habe auch einen Optimismus, weil ich im Netz natürlich auch viele Leute sehe und kennenlerne und es auch immer wieder neue gibt, die dazu kommen,
die diesen Gedanken und diese Überzeugung auch teilen und sich dafür einsetzen, und da merkt man schon, da hat sich schon eine Gemeinschaft gefunden,
die zwar im Kern auch eher etwas klein ist, das sind jetzt nicht enorm viele Leute, die jetzt genau so denken und auch über die schlichte Anwendung von Programmen
und didaktischen Methoden jetzt hinaus denken, aber da kommen schon auch immer wieder Leute dazu.
Man merkt, das findet auch an verschiedenen Orten Anklang, und das ist schon auch Grund für Optimismus.
Ja, einige haben wir hier bei Forschergeist auch schon dabei gehabt, jetzt auch dich.
Vielen Dank für die Ausführungen und wir werden das Thema hier auf jeden Fall auch noch weiter begleiten.
Danke auch.
Bis hierhin sage ich erst mal vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Das war es bei Forschergeist, es geht bald weiter.
Ich sage, tschüss und bis bald.